GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
WEDNESDAY MAY THE NINTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE I THINK AT
THIS POINT. WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF ONE
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE
MEASURES UP FOR VOTES AND CALL
ROLE.
WITH THAT WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR HERE.
MR MATHIS.
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B. NINETEEN
FIFTEEN.
MR MATHIS WELCOME.
WE.
DURING THE DAY.
THE BILL.
BILL THAT WOULD ACT OR.
WROTE.
AS FOR ALL WHERE LAUGHTER VIDAK
DID SENATE BILL TWO.
THE BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS ACT.
THIS MEASURE CREATED A SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLAR FEE ON EVERY REAL
ESTATE DOCUMENTS FOR EACH SINGLE
TRANSACTION. PER SINGLE PARCEL
OF REAL PROPERTY NOT TO EXCEED.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
FURTHERMORE.
THE MEASURE ESTABLISHED A
DEFINITION OF REAL ESTATE.
INSTRUMENT PAPER OR NOTICE
HOWEVER THE VAGUE SCOPE OF THIS
DEFINITION HAS CAUSED NUMEROUS
AGENCIES TO QUESTION WHICH
DOCUMENTS.
ONES THAT ARE NOT EXPLICITLY
LISTED WITHIN THE ACT ARE
SUBJECT TO THIS FEE INCREASE.
SINCE SB TWO WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE AGENCIES.
HAVE QUESTION THE LEGALITY OF
COLLECTION.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TO STATED THAT THEY DO
NOT BELIEVE THE TACK SHOULD
APPLY TO CHILD SUPPORT
DOCUMENTS.
COUNTY RECORDS.
RECORDERS.
HAVE OPENED THAT DAY TAX DOES
APPLY TO THESE DOCUMENTS ASPER
SH CORRECT READING OF THE NEW
LAW.
UNTIL A COURT RULING ON THE
MATTER IS FINALIZED MANY
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN LEFT TO
QUESTION THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
COLLECT THESE FEES AND THE
INTERNAL.
ONE SUCH TRADE BEFORE MISTER
CHILD LEAVES I WANT TO SEE IF WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MADAM SECRETARY
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IS
JUST WAITING FOR YOU TO FINISH
BUT I WANT TO DO IT BEFORE HE
LEAVES.
CHIU A HERE HERE MAIENSCHEIN
MENTIONED HERE CHAU.
CHAU YEAR CHOI HERE CHOI HERE
GLORIA LAMONT WHICH THANK YOU WE
HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU MISTER
CAL.
TAKE YOUR BACK TO MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMERCIAL
BREAK.
NOW THAT THE IN TERMS OVER.
.
ONE SUCH TRADE WHICH WILL BE
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THIS NEW
FEE.
CALIFORNIA'S PROSPEROUS MINING
INDUSTRY.
MONEY AND RECORDS ARE THE ONLY
TYPE OF DOCUMENT THAT HAS TO BE
FILED EVERY SINGLE YEAR. OR THE
OWNER COULD LOSE THEIR CLAIM
INDEFINITELY.
DUE TO THE NATURE OF MINERAL
EXPLORATION AND EXTRACTION.
IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR A SINGLE
PROJECT TO RESULT MULTIPLE MY
NAME DOCUMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
RECORDED.
FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR INYO
COUNTY A SINGLE CLAIM IT
RECORDED MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
MINING CLAIM LOCATION NOTICES
FOR A SINGLE PROJECT.
THE TOTAL COST.
TO RECORD THESE DOCUMENTS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WAS FOURTEEN.
THOUSAND DOLLARS
AS OF JANUARY ONE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE COSTS INCREASED TO
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TODAY MOST MINDS OR.
OPERATED BY SMALL PROSPECTORS
ATTEMPTED TO SEEK OUT A LIVING.
IN ORDER TO KEEP THEIR CLAIM THE
MINOR MUST EITHER PAY AN ANNUAL
FEE TO THE BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT OR PROVE THAT THEY
ARE ACTIVELY EXPLORING FOR
MINERALS.
IF THE IS UNABLE TO PAY.
THE NEW TAX TO RECORD THEIR
DOCUMENTS THEY WILL LOSE THEIR
CLAIM.
CALIFORNIA'S NON FUEL MINERAL.
PRODUCTION IS VALUED AT MORE
THAN.
THREE POINT SEVEN SIX BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
IN FACT CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE TO PRODUCE BORON WHICH IS
USED IN EVERYTHING FROM ROCKET
FUEL TO EYEDROPS TO AND ACCEPT.
IT IS ALSO HOME.
TO THE ONLY RARE EARTH MINE IN
THE NATION.
THERE IS ALSO PROMISE OF NEW
GREEN ENERGY MINERAL PRODUCTION.
WHICH IS IN THE EARLY STAGE OF
EXPLORATION.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT LITHIUM
HERE FOLKS.
HOWEVER THESE FOR.
THESE PRODUCTIONS.
ARE IN JEOPARDY OF BEING LOST.
DO TO THE FEE ESTABLISHED BY THE
BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS ACTS.
AND ANY MONEY OPERATION TO
CONTINUE DESPITE THE FEE ARE
LIKELY TO SHIFT COST.
FOR THESE MINERALS DOWN TO THE
CONSUMERS.
AS YOU ARE ALL AWARE LITHIUM IS
A KEY ASPECT IN MEDIAN AREN'T
FIRE MENTAL GOALS.
LITHIUM AND ITS COMPOUNDS
HAVE SEVERAL INDUSTRIAL
APPLICATIONS INCLUDING HEAT
RESISTANT GLASS AND CERAMICS.
WITH THE INCREASED LIVER CANCER
LITHIUM BATTERIES AND LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
TYPES OF RECHARGEABLE BATTERIES
FOR PORTABLE ELECTRONICS.
AND ARE ALSO GROWING IN
POPULARITY FOR MILITARY BATTER.
ELECTRICAL VEHICLES WERE E. VIS.
AND AEROSPACE APPLICATIONS.
AS OUR STATE BOLSTERS IN
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEY USE OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES WE MUST ACTIVELY SEEK
MEANS TO REDUCE COSTS. FOR THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE OVERSIGHT OF
LUMPING MINING CLAIM DOCUMENTS
INTO SENATE BILL TWO.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY HUNDRED THIS
PROGRESS.
AS THE COST TO EXTRACT THIS
VITAL RESOURCE SO TOO WILL THE
PRICE INCREASE FOR THINGS SUCH
AS CELL PHONES AND SOLAR PANELS.
ALL OF THIS TECH WILL SEE PRICE
INCREASES.
SPECIALLY IN THE GREEN TECH
MARKET.
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IS SCHEDULED TO
CONSIDER A PROPOSAL THIS
MORNING.
AT TEN AM SO HERE ABOUT THIRTY
MINUTES.
THAT WILL MANDATE MOST NEW HOMES
TO HAVE SOLAR PANELS STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY.
MOST SOLAR PANELS USE UTILIZE
LITHIUM AS THEIR PRIMARY BATTERY
SOURCE.
WITHOUT THE RELIEF OFFERED IN
THIS MEASURE. WE CAN CERTAINLY
EXPECT THE COST OF LIVING IN TO
INCREASE THEREBY INCREASING THE
PRICE OF SOLAR PANELS.
THESE COSTS DIRECTLY IN KEY
GREASE THE COST OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS WE DISCUSS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS WE MUST TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT.
THAT INACTION ON THIS PROPOSAL
WILL ULTIMATELY LEAD TO
INCREASES AND HOUSING COSTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTEEN
PROVIDES A SMALL EXEMPTION TO
THE PEER REVIEW OF. THE BUILDING
AND HOMES AND JOBS AT.
BY EXPLICITLY EXCLUDING MINING
CLAIMS
THE LEGISLATURE CAN PRESERVE
THIS PROSPEROUS INDUSTRY WHILE
ALSO ENSURE EARNING THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF GREEN ENERGY
MATERIALS FOR OUR GREEN TACK
KHANOM.
WE CANNOT HAMPER THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THIS KEY TECHNOLOGY AS WE
MOVE TOWARDS OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AS SUCH I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTES WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE CAN BE FOR. THE INYO COUNTY
CLERK RECORDER AND REGISTER. OF
VOTERS IN ADDITION TO ONE OF MY
WITNESSES COULD NOT. BE IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY.
AND I'D ASK THE SERGEANTS TO
PASS OUT THE HANDOUT SO IT MAY
BE ENTERED INTO THE RECORD.
AMIN.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS YOUR
WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS COUNTY
FOOT AND I'M ELECTED IN YOUR
COUNTY CLERK RECORDER I'M HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
WHEN THIS PRIME WHEN SB TWO WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR IT WAS
INITIALLY UNCLEAR WHETHER OR NOT
IT WOULD EVEN APPLY TO MINING
CLAIM DOCUMENTS WE HAD MANY MANY
CONVERSATIONS AMONGST COUNTY
RECORDERS. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THE MINING CLAIM DOCUMENTS ARE
DIFFERENT THAN ALL OF THE OTHER
DOCUMENTS LISTED ON IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE UNDER THIS
SECTION.
THEY ARE RECORDED AGAINST PUBLIC
LANDS ONCE THE MINERALS ARE
EXTRACTED THAT'S PERSONAL
PROPERTY IN THE LAND ALWAYS
REMAINS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
OWNERSHIP WHICH IS EXPLICITLY
EXEMPT FROM S. B. TO.
SO INSTEAD.
MINING CLAIM DOCUMENTS SEES ME
NOT INSTEAD BUT THEY'RE ALSO
UNIQUE IN ANOTHER WAY.
AND AS MR MATHIS SAID EARLIER
THEY ARE THE ONLY TYPE OF
DOCUMENT THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT
NEEDS TO BE RECORDED EVERY
SINGLE YEAR IN ORDER FOR THE
MINOR TO KEEP THEIR CLAIM.
SO IT MINOR. WHO HAS?
AS FOR INSTANCE FIVE CLAIMS
THEY'RE GONNA PAY AROUND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS
EVERY SINGLE YEAR OR UP TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A TEN YEAR
PERIOD IF YOU CONTRAST THAT
WITH.
THE TYPICAL HOMEOWNER WHO
REFINANCES THEIR PROPERTY MAYBE
TWICE IN THAT DECADE. THEY'RE
ONLY GOING TO PAY FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS SO ROUGHLY
AROUND TEN PERCENT OR A LITTLE
MORE THAN TEN PERCENT OF WHAT
THAT MINOR WILL PAY INTO THE
HOUSING FIND.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING WITH
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIFTEEN IS
JUST AND EQUITABLE COLLECTION
ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES AND ALL
PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND MAKE THAT CLARIFICATION
CLEAR IN THE LAW.
SO IN ADDITION A MINING CLAIMS
WHEN ADDED TOGETHER.
NOT ON THEIR OWN BUT Q.
MASSIVELY OF MAKE UP A LARGE
PORTION OF OUR LOCAL TAX BASE.
SO AS THESE CLAIMS GO OUT OF
EXISTENCE ARE LOCAL TAX BASE IN
INYO COUNTY IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE REDUCED AND THEN WERE NOT
ABLE TO RESPOND TO HELP OUR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AS ART
ON REVENUES OVERALL GO DOWN.
MOST MINES AND I WAS READING IN
THE ANALYSIS IT SAYS THAT THE
FEE WILL HAVE LITTLE IMPACT ON
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF THE
MINING INDUSTRY.
BUT JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
REGRESSIVE TAX.
THIS IS ONLY TRUE FOR THE
HANDFUL OF VERY PROFITABLE MINES
IN THE STATE.
IT'S A SMALL MINERS LIKE SEVENTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD KATE CONDI WHO
JUST LOST SEVEN CLAIMS LAST YEAR
IN INYO COUNTY. OR LIKE MY
FATHER WHO PASSED AWAY FIVE
YEARS AGO YET THREE CLAIMS UP
UNTIL THE DAY THAT HE DIED.
THESE ARE SMALL MINERS THAT MAKE
UP CUMULATIVELY A LARGE PORTION
OF OUR TAX BASE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR TODAY IS JUST A
CLARIFICATION. I WOULD JUST SAY
ONE LAST POINT. ARM OF THE EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION DOCUMENTS
RECORDED IN CALIFORNIA LAST
YEAR.
ONLY SIX THOUSAND OR LESS THAN
ZERO POINT ZERO ONE PERCENT.
WERE RELATED TO MINE SORT
TALKING ABOUT A VERY VERY SMALL
PORTION OF. THE OVERALL REVENUES
I WAS JUST SPEAKING OF STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE ON MONDAY.
IN THE FIRST QUARTER THIS FUND
IS ALREADY RECEIVED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN COLLECTION
AND THAT'S WITH TEN COUNTIES YET
TO REMIT THEIR FUNDING FOR THE
FIRST QUARTER SO IT'S WELL ON
ITS WAY. TO MEET ITS PROJECTIONS
AND WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR
CLARIFICATION AND A VERY VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
SO I AM ASKING.
THAT TODAY. THIS COMMITTEE WILL
VOTE YES ND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN AND JOIN OTHER WESTERN
STATES SUCH AS WASHINGTON AND
OREGON TO THE SP TWO WAS MODELED
AFTER. WHO HAVE ALSO EXEMPTED
MINING CLAIMS FROM THIS ITEM
HOUSING TAX?
THANK YOU I MAKE A MOTION.
VETERANS MADE A MOTION.
LET ME ASK IF THERE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
IS THERE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
THE ONE OF.
TO THE TABLE.
THE MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TYRONE BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TO STRENUOUSLY OBJECT
TO THIS BILL AND OPPOSE IT
TODAY.
SP TO JUST PASSED LAST YEAR WE
WERE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THAT LEGISLATION.
IT TOOK YEARS AND YEARS TO GET
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MULTIPLE
ITERATIONS AND ULTIMATELY LAST
YEAR WE'VE. ACHIEVED THE
BUILDING HOMES AND JOBS ACT
WHICH WILL BUILD BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I'M IT'S AND
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IT CREATES A RELIABLE
AND STABLE AND PERMANENT SOURCE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS EVERY YEAR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAKES
MULTIPLE YEARS TO PRODUCE TAKES.
MULTIPLE.
DIFFERENT SOURCES OF FUNDING TO
PRODUCE AND.
THE VALUE OF HAVING THIS
HOUSING FUND AVAILABLE TO MAKE
SURE TO BE THERE EVERY YEAR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS IS
VITAL.
EXEMPTION SUCH AS THESE.
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF THE BILL
AND UNDERMINE THEPURPOSE WHICH
AGAIN IS TO CREATE RELIABLE AND
PERMITS OR STE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED THAT
ALLOWING EXEMPTION SUCH AS THESE
WILL CREATE A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
THAT WILL BRING EVERY INTEREST
GROUP OUT OF THE WOODWORK TO.
ULTIMATELY.
SEEKING THE SAME TYPE OF
EXEMPTION AND ULTIMATELY
DECIMATE THE HOUSING TRUST FUND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
OPPOSE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF. OF
MY COLLEAGUE AND.
ENDORSE THEM I WOULD ONLY JUST
ADD THAT.
THE FUND WAS JUST ESTABLISH
SAYS AS HE SAID AND THE FUN AND
THE MONIES HAVE JUST STARTED TO
BE COLLECTED IN JANUARY AND
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE FINAL AS
WAS NOTED WE DON'T KNOW THE
AMOUNT THAT WILL COME IN IN THE
FIRST QUARTER. SO WE'RE STILL
GETTING OUR SEA LEGS IN TERMS OF
WHAT THIS PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING WILL MEAN FOR THE STATE
AND AS TYRONE SAID IT NEEDS TO
BE YOU KNOW A STABLE RELIABLE
SOURCE. AND THE MORE THAT WE
START TO CREATE EXEMPTIONS IT
WILL CREATE A SLIPPERY SLOPE AND
UNDERMINE THE VALUE OF THE FUND
TO THE STATE. WE HAVE A HOUSING
BOND THAT'S ON THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT YET TO BE VOTED ON SO
THIS IS THE THE LYNCH PIN OF
AVAILABLE FUNDING UP FRONT RIGHT
NOW THAT WE HAVE SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
OPPONENTS.
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION.
MR MATHIS OF YOU AND I'VE HAD
SOME CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS IN
THE FIRST.
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY FOR YOUR DISTRICT.
I KNOW THAT THE MINING INDUSTRY
IS ONE THAT IS CENTERED.
IN YOUR PART OF THE STATE.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT INDUSTRY IN
OUR STATE AND.
PLOT YOU FOR THINKING OF
CREATIVE WAYS TO TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD. AS AS YOU AND I
DISCUSSED OUR I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
TODAY I AND I DO HAVE A NO
RECOMMENDATION TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
I WILL SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT
IT.
.
AS YOU HEARD AND YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED S.
B. TWO AND IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
AFTER MANY MANY YEARS OF
DISCUSSION. THAT WE FINALLY
ESTABLISH WITH A DIFFICULT TO
ACHIEVE TWO THIRDS VOTE.
CREATING A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE MOST INTENSE HOUSING
CRISIS OUR STATE HAS HAD. ON AND
THERE ARE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
HAVE SUGGESTED POTENTIAL
EXCEPTIONS OR CARVE OUTS FOR SP
TWO. ARE IN THE FIRST FEW MONTHS
OF OF COLLECTING THESE REVENUES
AND AT THIS TIME GIVEN THE
CRISIS GIVEN WHERE WE ARE I
CAN'T SUPPORT CARVE OUTS.
.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST MENTION WITH
REGARDS TO THIS INDUSTRY I HEARD
YOU USE PHRASES ABOUT HOW SB TWO
COULD BE THE RUIN OF THIS
INDUSTRY BUT YOU ALSO REFLECT
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A VERY
PROSPEROUS INDUSTRY.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE A SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS FEE IN THE CONTEXT
OF A THREE POINT SEVEN SIX
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
SEEMS DE MINIMUS AND AS YOUR
WITNESS HAD POINTED OUT A MINING
CLAIMS THE REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS ONLY REPRESENT I
THINK YOU SAID ZERO POINT ZERO
ONE PERCENT. OF THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT SO. I
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THE THE
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT ON YOUR
INDUSTRY THAT I I KNOW YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
ALL THIS BEING SAID AS I
SUGGESTED TO YOU I THINK THERE'S
A DIFFERENT WAY IF THE MINE
INDUSTRY IS IN FACT IN JEOPARDY.
OF OF OF TRYING TO MOVE FOR
OTHER POLICIES TO HELP IT. I
JUST THINK THAT IN THE CONTEXT
OF SP TO THE IDEA CARVE OUT AT
THIS TIME IS NOT ONE THAT.
I THOUGHT THAT I CAN SUPPORT I'M
AND I DO WANT TO SAY TO A
WITNESS WE HAD INTENDED WITH THE
THE THE WRITING OF THIS BILL TO
INCLUDE THE REAL ESTATE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE IN ITS
UNFORTUNATELY. THAT DID CAPTURE
ON THE DOCUMENTS WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND THAT WAS PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT
SO.
SO THAT IS MY PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS I I'M HAPPY TO HAVE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS. ON ONE
LAST THOUGHT I HAD IS IF OUR
MINING INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME ONLY AND
CALIFORNIA MINERALS.
.
I THINK THERE'S LESS OF A
CONCERN ABOUT US LOSING MINING
BUSINESS. WITH.
MINERALS THAT ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE IN OUR STATE TO OTHER
STATES SO SO THAT ALSO SOMETHING
THAT I'VE WAIT A AS I. CONSIDER
MY PERSPECTIVE ON THAT SO.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WILL BE ABLE
TO BE WITH YOU ON THIS BILL
TODAY.
BUT THE FOR TO FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS.
OTHER CONVERSATION.
WITH THAT.
BACK TO FOR. CLOSING COMMENTS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
.
THE YOU KNOW I THINK.
I OFTENTIMES WE THINK A MINER'S
WE THINK OF.
AND AN OLD GUY WITH A BEARD
WITH A PICKAXE WEARING OVERALLS
OF GOLDEN TEETH AND THAT'S
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
.
YOU KNOW MY LARGEST CONCERN IS
AS WE'VE GONE OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
IS THE FACT OF.
THE NEXT.
BLESSEDLY WITH THE LITHIUM
MARKETS.
.
NINO EYES AS YOU STATED IN YOUR
IN YOUR COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR
YOU KNOW THE CONCERN OF OF THE
MINING INDUSTRY.
IT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE MINING INDUSTRY
BUT IT'S OUR GREEN TECH INDUSTRY
AND WHAT THE CAUSE OF THIS
INFLATION WILL DO TO OUR STATE.
AND THE BOOMING TECH ECONOMY
THAT WE HAVE.
DO THE ARGUMENTS MADE BY MAR
OUR FOLKS THAT WERE PROPONENTS
OF SP TO IN REGARDS TO.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP
HOUSING AFFORDABLE.
AS.
I STATED EARLIER.
THERE'S A VOTE HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE SOLAR
PANELS TO BE ON ALL NEW HOUSES
IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU INCREASE THE COST OF
SOLAR.
YOU THEN.
INCREASE THE COST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO TO ASK FOR A SMALL MINUTE
AMOUNT.
TO BE RELIEVED FOR THE MINING
INDUSTRY WHICH IS THE ONLY
INDUSTRY THAT HAVE TO DO THIS
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
AGAIN EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
ANYBODY ELSE THAT THE CLAIM.
FIFTY YEARS GOES BY THAT THERE
FIND IT ONCE IN A LIFETIME.
FOR ARE MINING INDUSTRY IT'S
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
THIS IS GONNA HAD INCREASED
INFLATION IT'S GONNA.
DRIVE THE COST OF SOLAR OF IT'S
GOING TO DRIVE THE COST OF
LITHIUM UP.
JENNA CREATE INFLATION.
ARE NEW HOUSING IS NOT GOING TO
BE AFFORDABLE BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASED COST.
.
I JUST HOPE YOU ALL CONSIDER
THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LET'S KEEP HOUSING
AFFORDABLE LET'S KEEP SOLAR
AFFORDABLE. AND LET'S KEEP GREEN
TECH AFFORDABLE I ASK YOU FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND I APPRECIATE CAN APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY AND. I DO THINK THAT IF
THERE REALLY IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO DO HERE ARE PROPOSING.
EH ATTACKS
BREAK TO THIS INDUSTRY MIGHT BE%
A OF A DIFFERENT WAY TO GO WHEN
AND SOMETHING WE CAN CONSIDER.
I'M I'M STILL NOT CONVINCED.
THAT THERE IS GONNA BE THE
IMPACT THAT I KNOW YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND. OBVIOUSLY
WE'LL SEE THAT OVER TIME I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE RELATIVELY DE
MINIMUS BUT.
LOOK FOR TEN MONITORING THAT AS
THESE REVENUES ARE COLLECTED UP
WITH THAT.
THERE'S A MOTION. TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD BY.
BY DOCTR CHOI AND THAT'S BEEN
SECONDED.
MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PESTER THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHU KNOW TO KNOW. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN VOTING CHAO.
CHOI.
I.
CHOI AYE.
GLORIA. LEMOND WOULD.
OF THAT BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. MISTER
CHAIR MASS FOR RECONSIDERATION
OF ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OUR NEXT BILL WILL BE PRESENTED
BY OUR COLLEAGUE MISTER FRAZIER
HAS FILE ITEM THREE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY TWO.
MISTER FRAZIER WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
TWO IS AN EFFORT TO HELP IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH A
VALUABLE TOOL CREATED LAST YEAR.
WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES.
AS YOU KNOW THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA DOES NOT ONLY
AFFECT LOW INCOME BUT MIDDLE
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES. AND
THESE AUTHORITIES.
ALSO PROVIDE FOR WORKFORCE
HOUSING UP TO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
PERCENT. OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME.
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS MAKE UP
ABOUT NINE PERCENT OF AN AVERAGE
HOUSING PROJECTS COSTS.
WITH THE STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES INVESTING SO MUCH INTO
HOUSING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED
THESE PROJECT HIS UP TO CODE AND
HAS THE CAPACITY.
FOR THIS LARGER.
AMOUNT OF. UNITS.
AND THAT'S THE LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL HOUSING DOLLARS. TO GO
FURTHER ALSO.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY TWO EXPANDS
THE SCOPE OF AN AUTHORITY TO
INCLUDE PROVIDING FOR WATER
SEWER ELECTRICAL STREETS AND
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY.
FOR A VERY WORTHWHILE PROJECT.
TO PROVIDE INSIGHT ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN THE NEED
TO CONNECT HIGH QUALITY OF THE
STRUCTURES MICHAEL LANE WITH A
NON. PROFIT ASSOCIATION A
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
MISTER LANG.
CHURCH END MEMBERS.
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS A RECALL
ASHTRAY BICU FIFTEEN NINETY
WORK ON THAT VERY CLOSELY WITH
WITH MR MULLIN. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE MISTER FRAZIER IN THE
ENGINEERS BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THIS YEAR IN TERMS OF.
CITE STRUCTURALLY DID TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS VERY
NARROWLY TARGETED IN THE
ACTIVITIES THAT CAN BE INVESTED
IN AN AND THE LOCATIONS AND
DIRECTLY TIED. TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU KNOW AS WE TRY TO DO
INFILL DEVELOPMENT OFTENTIMES WE
DO NEED TO UPGRADE WATER SEWER
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE A TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN THEN DELIVER
THOSE UNITS AYE WITH MINIMAL
IMPACT. AND ALSO PROVIDE A
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT ONTO THE TWO
NEIGHBORING.
PARCELS AS WELL AND SO WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL IT'S.
COMPLETELY KATAKAN FLINTRIDGE
OUR EXISTING TAX WRITE FINANCING
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT IT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS RICHARD MARX AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF CIVIL ENGINEERS NINETEEN
THOUSAND CIVIL ENGINEERS AND
PUBLIC AND. PRIVATE PRACTICE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS A
REASONABLE EXPANSION OF THE
AUTHORITY IT. MAKES PERFECT
SENSE WE SUPPORT.
OKAY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE IN
DISCUSSION.
MR MAJOR.
THANK YOU I MISTER CHAIRMAN AT
DISTRICT.
ONE OR TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU BY
MISTER FRAZIER IF. THIS DOESN'T.
.
IN OTHER WORDS THIS EXPANDS THE
SCOPE OF WHAT FUNDS CAN BE USED
FOR NOT HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
ACQUIRED IS THAT CORRECT NO
WHATSOEVER THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
JUST REFINING. HOW THE THE FUNDS
CAN BE UTILIZED AND ENHANCE WHAT
IS ALREADY BEEN THERE? AND
STATURE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER ONE APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR WORK ON THIS I THINK
THIS IS.
A GOOD AN APPROPRIATE FOLLOW UP
TO MISTER BOLICK MELONS BILL
FROM LAST YEAR AND HOW WE.
ESTABLISH FOR THE HOUSING BY
ENSURING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY TO FUND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS RELATED
TO THAT FOR A HOUSING APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE MEMBERS ON THIS.
AND HAVE A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION TO THE COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT LACERTAE FINAL COMMENTS.
BACK TO YOU FOR ANY FINAL
COMMENTS
WELL MISTER MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH IN BEING A
LEADER IN THIS IN THIS ARENA FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
WORKFORCE HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
BUT I'D LIKE TO INCLUDE ALSO A
CATEGORY ARE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION IS DESPERATELY IN
NEED OF HOUSING ALSO. IF WE CAN
WORK TOWARDS IT INCLUDING THAT
POPULATION. WITH THESE CLOSURES
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
ALSO.
THE INTEGRATION INTO SOCIETY WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. TO CAPTURE
THAT.
ALSO IN OUR IN OUR EFFORTS
SENATE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT. WITH THAT I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AND AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PASSION LEADERSHIP ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPECIAL NEED.
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA UP WITH
THAT IS OUR MOTION WITH THIS
FOR.
SO MOVED HIS OUR SECOND.
I'LL SECOND THAT JOB IS A MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
UP FOR MISTER FRASIER'S BILL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
CHOI NO SHOW YOU KNOW.
GLORIA LEE MONTH. THE MONTH I
WOULD.
WE'LL HOLD YOUR BILL OPEN FOR
FURTHER AT ARMS THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTATION PICKING THIS JURY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR MARTZ ITCHY HIGHER FILE ITEM
FOR AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX.
WELCOME.
SIR.
GOOD MORNING WITH SHARON MEMBERS
THAT I AM HERE TO PERCENT EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX. WHICH
SEEKS TO REQUIRE LANDLORDS OF
RENT CONTROLLED.
APARTMENT TED DWELLINGS TO
APPROVE.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INSULATION
REQUESTS.
THIS IS.
AND AFTER THAT I. THAT I'M
CONTINUING FROM.
AND EARLIER BILL THAT I
INTRODUCED IN MY FIRST TERM.
WHICH WAS TO REQUIRE.
.
ALL A WRECK ALL DWELLINGS
TO ALLOW.
TENANTS
TO INSTALL ON THEIR OWN COST.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS.
AS WE ALL KNOW. THE EEVEE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
CRITICAL TO.
ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
AND OUR FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AGAINST AIR
POLLUTION.
GETTING.
EXPANDING THE EEVEE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING TO LEAD
TO.
MEETING OUR.
AGGRESSIVE GOALS OF GETTING
MORE E. VIS ONTO OUR.
ROADS IN OUR FREEWAYS.
THIS IS.
AN AREA THAT THAT WAS EXEMPTED
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH MY
EARLIER BELL.
.
THAT SAID WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT A SPECIAL COMMITTEES LIKE
IT'S YOUR CISCO WERE OVER
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF. THE
AVAILABLE RENTAL STOCK IS.
.
RENT CONTROL.
THAT.
.
ATTENDANCE OF RENT CONTROL UNITS
I DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO INSULATE
INSTALL AB CHARGING.
STATIONS ON THEIR OWN DIME.
I'M HERE TO.
.
PRESENT THIS BILL WITH THE
SUPPORT OF PAUL SCOTT OF PLUG IN
AMERICA IN CORE BULLETS WITH
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING STATE
ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KORABL SOME HALF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE A TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF EVEN CHARGING
COMPANIES THAT MANUFACTURE
INSTALL AND OPERATE HEAVEY
CHARGING EQUIPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SERVICES THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER CALLS
FOR TUNER FIFTY THOUSAND EVEY
CHARGING STATIONS TO BE PLOY TO
BUY. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND OF
THAT AMOUNT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS CALCULATED THAT
AROUND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND ARE GOING TO NEED TO BE
AT. A MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS.
AND MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS AND
MANY OF THEM WHICH ARE RENTAL
UNITS AS MR MERCHANT YOU STATED.
.
THEY'RE A TOUGH NUT TO CRACK IN
TERMS OF GETTING CHARGING
STATIONS DEPLOYED ON THE GROUND.
YOU KNOW OUR ASSOCIATION IN ITS
MEMBERS STAND READY TO RISE TO
THE CHALLENGE OF GETTING AS MANY
CHARGING STATIONS DEPLOYED SO
THAT WE CAN REACH OUR.
GOALS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE BUT
MANY BARRIERS REMAIN PERMITTING
REGULATORY OR OTHERWISE THAT
WOULD INHIBIT OUR ABILITY TO
DEPLOY THINGS.
TO DEPLOY STATIONS ON THE
GROUND A SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX
WILL HELP.
TAKE US A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY BOLSTERING.
CONSUMER ACCESS TO YOU THE
STATIONS IN THE US ARM
CONFIDENCE IN PURCHASING DVDS I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
I MEAN.
.
MY NAME IS PAUL SKYPE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING ON TWO
YEARS AGO I MET AND FELL IN LOVE
WITH THE WOMAN WHO LIVES IN AN
APARTMENT IN LOS ANGELES.
AS WE GOT TO KNOW EACH OTHER I
TOLD HER ABOUT ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AND RENEWABLE ENERGY. AND
CONVINCED HER THAT SHE SHOULD
SWITCHER APARTMENTS ELECTRICITY
TO A CLEAN SOURCE THROUGH HER
UTILITY SHE DIDN'T IMMEDIATELY
AND SHE HAS POWER HER HOME WITH
CLEAN ELECTRICITY SENT.
I ALSO CONVINCED HER TO GET A
USED D. V. AS HER PARKING SPACE
WAS ONLY FIFTY FEET AWAY FROM
HER ELECTRICAL PANEL SO IT WOULD
BE AN EASY TO INSTALL A CHARTER.
HOWEVER WHEN I APPROACHED HER
LANDLORD AND EXPLAINED WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO THERE WAS NO
RESPONSE AYE CAT CONTACTED THEM
FIVE TIMES OVER SEVERAL MONTHS.
EACH TIME EXPLAINING THAT WE
WANTED TO INTALL A CHARGER FOR
MTV. I KNEW ABOUT AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY FIVE BUT HE ALSO KNEW
THEE WAS A CARVE OUT FOR RENT
CONTROL APARTMENT MEANING THOSE
RENTERS DID NOT HAVE THE RIGHT
TO USE THEIR OWN ELECTRICITY. TO
POWER THEIR CARS.
BARBOUR LIVES IN A RENT
CONTROLLED APARTMENT SO HER
LANDLORD COULD LEGALLY DENY HER
THE RIGHT TO USE HER OWN CLEAN
ELECTRICITY TO POWER HER CAR.
THERE ARE NO PUBLIC CHARGERS IN
HER NEIGHBORHOOD SO SHE COULD
NOT GET THAT HE'D BE SHE
CONTINUES DRIVING A GAS BURNING
CAR TODAY.
WHEN I SAW THAT THERE WAS A
SINGLE FIFTEEN WORD LINE IN AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE
DISALLOWING RENT CONTROL TENANTS
FROM HAVING THE RIGHT TO USED
THEIR OWN CLEAN ENERGY TO POWER
THEIR CARS. I CONTACTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AMERITECH SOCHI AND ASKED
IF HE WOULD WRITE A NEW LAW THAT
CORRECTED THIS PROBLEM AND
THAT'S HOW AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SIX CAME TO BE.
FROM MY RESEARCH I'VE LEARNED
THAT THERE OVER HALF A MILLION
RENT CONTROL UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE CAN SWITCH
FROM BURNING GASOLINE UNLESS
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO A CHARTER
WHERE THEY WORK WHICH THE VAST
MAJORITY DO NOT.
THOUSANDS OF THESE PEOPLE WOULD
PROBABLY SWITCH IMMEDIATELY IF
THEY COULD INSTALL A CHARGER AT
HOME THIS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE
OF LOW HANGING FRUIT.
USING DIRTY ENERGY ELECTRICITY
FROM COAL AND GAS AND OIL FOR
TRANSPORTATION. IS FOR MOST
PEOPLE THE SINGLE WORST THING
THEY DO IN THEIR ENTIRE LIVES.
WITH AFFORDABLE ELECTRIC CARS
AND LOW COST RENEWABLE ENERGY
MOST PEOPLE CAN NOW SWITCH TO A
CLEAN LOW IMPACT LAUGHED
LIFESTYLE. BUT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT CLEAN ENERGY
WITH THEIR CARS AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SIX WILL DO THAT FOR OVER
HALF A MILLION CALIFORNIANS I
URGE YOU TO PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
BANKING.
MORTON CARVE ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
PULLING MEASURE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD ONE OF
THE RENT CONTROLLED CITIES IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKUP PRAYER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF CHARGE POINT WE WERE.
A SUPPORTER OF THE UNDERLYING
STATUTE.
THAT MISTER MAYOR TO CHI
AUTHORED.
AND WE WANT.
JR I VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE CAPITOL
INTERPRETS AND PLUG IN AMERICA I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN THE
ORIGINAL STATUTE WHICH WE WORKED
WITH HIM ON AND SENATOR
QUARTERBACK TO REMOVE THESE
TYPES OF BARRIERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE SUPPORT BILL. THANK YOU.
TOM EDISON WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HAVE ONE QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR WHY WAS THIS EXEMPTED
IN YOUR FIRST BILL. O. THERE
WERE SOME OBJECTIONS AND
CONCERNS RAISED.
ABOUT HER.
SOME PERCEIVED TO.
CONCERNS ABOUT INSTALLATION FOR
RENT CONTROL UNITS BUT.
APPARENTLY THOSE CONCERNS.
.
ARE NOT SIGNIFICANT AT THIS
POINT GREATLY HOT DE BASED ON
NOW SEEN OPPOSITION. THERE'S
BEEN FILED FOR BILL.
I WILL SAY.
AS SOME HAVE BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING FORWARD THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE VISION FOR
STATE IN A FEW YEARS AGO HAD
PASSED A A A LOT TO HELP
STREAMLINE THE INSTALLATION OF
CHARGING STATIONS. AND AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS ONE OF
THESE RENT CONTROL CITIES AND
LIVED IN A RED CONTROL FOR
TWENTY YEARS MYSELF AND WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD TO
LIVE IN MY CITY BUT FOR THAT.
I THINK THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE NO
BRAINER IN HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
AND REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OPTICALLY IN OUR DENSE
URBAN CITIES.
IF THIS BILL GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE I'M HAPPY TO AT MYSELF
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE BILL IF
THAT IS THE PLEASURE OF THE
AUTHOR.
WITH THAT IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION MISTER CHOI.
YEAH I HAVE A. QUESTION I KNOW
WOULD BE IN SUPPORT IN THE
CONCEPT HOWEVER. THE IS SYSTEM
REQUIRING PROPERTY OWNERS.
TO ALLOW.
.
IS SETTING UP BUT AYE EVEY AYE
CHARGING.
STATIONS SO WHO'S GONNA PAY IS
HAD GONE LAND ALSO
RESPONSIBILITY OR WHAT WOULD YOU
ASK.
ALLOW THAT. TO.
SET UP A CHARGING STATION YES
DOCTOR CHOICE THE TENANT
SERVICES A WHEN WHEN. YOU KNOW
WE ALLOW TENANTS TO BE ABLE TO
INSTALL THE CHARGING STATIONS
AND THE LANDLORD BENEFITS FROM A
PROPERTY UPGRADE.
A PAID FOR BY THE TENANT
OKAY YEAH THAT THAT THE US.
YEAH FAIR I THOUGHT THAT THIS
WAS A AND OF THE BURDEN OF FOR
THE. THEIR PROPERTY OWNERS IT'S
A BENEFIT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEN ON HOW DO ANY FINAL
COMMENTS LIKE TO EXPECT LAST
VERY AYE OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
MARTUCCI WITH THAT IS OUR MOTION
WITH THIS FOR.
THEIR SECOND.
UP MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS CHU. CHU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
CHOI NINE CHILE AYE GLORIA PLEA
MONTH.
THE MONTH I WOULD.
FOUR ZERO YOUR BILL IS APPLE
WILL WAIT FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK TAKE.
WHEN WE CALL OTHER AUTHORS TO
SEE IF WE CAN CONTINUE OTHER
PRESENTATIONS
BUT
WE'VE TO YOU'RE BARELY CROSS THE
HALL SO
HOPEFULLY ONE OF THEM WILL BE
ABLE TO COME BACK SHORTLY AND WE
CAN CONTINUE THE MEETING
THIS. WAS WATER IN A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
IS THAT A MOTION MOVES THEIR
SECOND.
THINK INTERESTED CHAIR.
JUST BRIEFLY I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
THREE.
WHICH BRIDGES A GAP IN EXISTING
LAW ALLOWING MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS DEVASTATED FROM THE
RECENT FIRES TO REBUILD THEIR
HOMES AND OBTAIN A STANDARDIZED
LONG. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY. AND
OF.
WITH.
JR AYE VOTE DUE TO THE LILAC
FIRE IN SAN DIEGO OF THE HUNDRED
FIFTY STRUCTURES THAT WERE
DESTROYED AT LEAST SEVENTY FIVE
WERE MANUFACTURED HOMES.
BURNED TO THE GROUND AND OTHERS
WERE SERIOUSLY DAMAGED.
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO REBUILD
THEY FOUND THAT THEY COULD NO
LONGER OBTAIN A TRADITIONAL
LOAN.
BECAUSE OF A GAP ON THE LAW AND
THIS THIS BILL AIMS TO FIX THAT.
I'M WITH ME TODAY IS BILL SMITH
WHO WORKS AS A LENDER IN
SPECIALIZING IN REVERSE
MORTGAGES FOR THE PURCHASE A
MANUFACTURED HOMES HE'S ALSO AN
OWNER IN RANCHO MONSERRAT. WHICH
WAS THE PARK DESTROYED BY THE
LILAC FIRE.
SU LOFTON IS AN ATTORNEY WHO HAS
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
VICTIMS OF THE LILAC FIRE. TO
OBTAIN FINANCING TO REBUILD
THEIR HOMES.
YOUR WITNESSES.
IT. AYE GOOD MORNING OF CHAIRMAN
AND COMMISSIONER ARE SORRY OF.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M STILL OFTEN I'M AN ATTORNEY
WHO'S WORKED WITH MOBILE HOME
PARKS FOR.
ALMOST FORTY YEARS
I THIS IS A VERY FOCUSED.
I AMENDMENT TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE EIGHTEEN FIVE FIVE ONE.
I EIGHTEEN FIVE FIVE ONE PER
METS PERMANENT FOUNDATIONS FOR
RESIDENT KNOWN PARKS.
I DO TO A CHANGE IN
INTERPRETATION OF REAL PROPERTY
WHICH IS A TERM IN THE STATUTE.
RESIDENTS AND CONDOMINIUM
MOBILE HOME PARKS CANNOT OBTAIN.
FINANCING AND I'M GONNA ALLOW
MISTER SMITH TO GO THROUGH THE
FINANCING ISSUES.
ME THIS CREATES
FOR THE CONDOMINIUM MOBILE HOME
PARKS
WHICH ARE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A AND. I. AM PROVIDE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
LIFESTYLE.
CHOICES FOR BOTH SENIORS AND FOR
FAMILIES.
WITHOUT THE FINANCING.
ARE THERE RESIDENTS ARE A CANNOT
SELL.
A UNLESS SOMEBODY CAN TAKE.
OR THEY HAVE CARRY BACK
FINANCING WHICH GENERALLY MEANS
THEY DON'T GET PAID AND MY
EXPERIENCE.
ARE THEY CANNOT.
.
REFINANCE THEIR HOME THEY CANNOT
REPLACE THEIR HOME.
THEY CANNOT GET MONEY TO REPAIR
THEIR HOME. SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
A EVER AN ARENA OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THAT WITH ONE SMALL CHANGE TO
INCLUDE AND THE DEFINITION FOR
THIS STATUTE. OF REAL PROPERTY
FOR AYE TO INCLUDE THE
CONDOMINIUM MOBILE HOME PARKS.
I IN ADDITION TO ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT COOPS IN THE
SUBDIVISIONS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
PERMANENT FOUNDATIONS.
I THESE PARKS
I THE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THEIR
HOUSING STOCK.
WITH REGARD TO THE URGENCY.
IT IS.
.
NOT ONLY DOES IT A FACT THE
RESIDENTS AND.
RANCHO MONSERRAT.
THERE ARE MOBILE HOMES THAT
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED AND SOME OF
THE PARKS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I THIS WILL ASSIST THEM IN BEING
ABLE TO REPLACE HIM PUT IN NEW
HOMES.
WHICH IS OUR IMMEDIATE URGENT
NEED OUR LONG TERM NEED IS THE
PRESERVATION OF THIS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I'M WILLIAM SMITH I'M
A MANUFACTURED HOME DEVELOPER
MORTGAGE LOAN OFFICER AN OWNER
OF MANUFACTURED HOMES IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FIFTY FIVE PLUS.
CONDOMINIUM DEVELOPMENTS.
MY TESTIMONY IS ON BEHALF OF
NINETEEN NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE OWNERS OF
MANUFACTURED HOMES IN RANCHO
MONSERRAT CHAMPAGNE VILLAGE AND
LAKE JENNINGS PARK ESTATES.
FORT CONDOMINIUM COMMUNITIES ARE
DAMAGED BY THAT SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUILDING DEPARTMENTS REFUSAL. TO
ISSUE FOR THIRTY THREE A PERMITS
ADDITIONALLY SENIORS RECENTLY
STRUCK BY TRAGEDY IN ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES ARE ESPECIALLY HARM.
ON DECEMBER SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE LILAC
FIRE DESTROYED SEVENTY FIVE
MANUFACTURED HOMES AND SEVERELY
DAMAGED OTHERS. IN THE FIFTY
FIVE PLUS RANCHO MONSERRAT
COMMUNITY NEAR FALLBROOK.
THE COUNTY'S REFUSAL TO ISSUE
FOR THIRTY THREE A PERMITS FOR
THE NEW REPLACEMENT HOMES. FOR
THE SIXTY THROUGH NINETEEN YEAR
OLD HOMEOWNERS HAS COMPROMISED
THEIR LIVES.
AND FORTUNES BECAUSE WITHOUT THE
FOUR THIRTY THREE EIGHT PERMITS.
THERE FINANCING OPTIONS AND
RECOVERIES ARE SERIOUSLY
IMPEDED.
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING
DEPARTMENT REVISED ITS
INTERPRETATION OF CODE SECTION
EIGHTEEN FIVE FIVE ONE. IT
REFUSES FOR THIRTY THREE A
PERMITS OF A CONDO PLANS
DEFINITION OF THE LIVING UNIT.
DOES NOT SPECIFY THE DIRT OR
SOIL UNDER THE HOME. IF A LIVING
UNIT IS DESCRIBED AS A SEPARATE
INTEREST IN A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT. THE PERMIT HAS
REFUSED.
IT CONTINUES TO ISSUE FOR THIRTY
THREE A PERMITS FOR CONDO UNITS
WHERE THE LIVING UNIT
DESCRIPTION INCLUDES THE GROUND
OR THE SOIL IN EACH LOT.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO IS THE LANGUAGE USED DECADES
AGO WHEN THE KONDO PLANS WERE
ORIGINALLY APPROVED.
BEFORE IT'S REVISED
INTERPRETATION THE DEPARTMENT
ISSUED THE FOUR THIRTY THREE A
PERMITS IN THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES.
WE CAN FIND NO OTHER
JURISDICTION TAKING THE SAME
POSITION AS THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUILDING DEPARTMENT.
AB NINETEEN FORTY THREE
CORRECTIONAL MISSION ARE
OVERSIGHT THAT OCCURRED WHEN
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION
EIGHTEEN FIVE FIVE ONE WAS
DRAFTED. AND I BELIEVE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE.
RESIDENTIAL UNITS OWNED AS A
SEPARATE INTEREST IN A COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT OR
CONDOMINIUMS WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE DEFINITION OF REAL
PROPERTY.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING
DEPARTMENT IS RELYING ON THIS
OMISSION FOR ITS PERMIT REFUSAL.
HAD THE LANGUAGE CONTAINED IN AB
NINETEEN FORTY THREE BEEN ISSUED
TO ENCODE SECTION EIGHTEEN FIVE
FIVE ONE WHEN IT WAS ORIGINATED
WE WOULD NOT BE GATHERED HERE
TODAY.
WITHOUT A FOUR THIRTY THREE A A
HOMES PROPERTY VALUE AND
MARKETABILITY ARE REDUCED WHEN
IT'S TIME TO SELL. BECAUSE MOST
MANUFACTURED HOME MORTGAGE
LENDERS REQUIRE FOR THIRTY THREE
ABLE AS A LOAN CONDITION.
WITHOUT A FOR THIRTY THREE A
SELLERS MAY ONLY BE ABLE TO
ATTRACT CASH BUYERS WHO
TYPICALLY OFFER LESS THAN IF A
MORTGAGE IS ATTAINABLE.
THIS DIMINISHES HOME VALUES.
CONVERSELY BEYER'S OF A PROPERTY
WITHOUT A FOUR THIRTY THREE A
ARE LIMITED TO THE FEWER NUMBER
OF LENDERS. WHO ACCEPT THE FOUR
THIRTY THREE C.? AS AN
ALTERNATIVE.
PLEASE LENDERS OFTEN CHARGE
GREATER LOAN FEES AND HIGHER
INTEREST RATES.
THE COUNTY'S REFUSAL TO EACH OF
THE FOUR THIRTY THREE A PERMITS
ADVERSELY AFFECT ADVERSELY
AFFECTS.
TWELVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND BY OUR COUNT NEARLY THREE
THOUSAND SENIORS IN FOR SAN
DIEGO AREA CONDOMINIUM
COMMUNITIES.
WHO BLOCKED THEIR HOMES
BELIEVING THAT THEY WERE
PURCHASING REAL ESTATE? THAT
INCLUDED THE LAND.
AB NINETEEN FORTY THREE SOLVES
THE PROBLEM FOR BOTH THE
DESERVING SENIOR CITIZENS
RESIDING IN THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES. AND FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO BUILDING
DEPARTMENT.
AS CALIFORNIA GRAPPLES WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CORRECTING AN
AGE OLD OVERSIGHT THROUGH
LEGISLATION WITH FEW. IF ANY
NEGATIVE OR FISCAL IMPACTS IS
WHAT YOUR CONSTITUENTS DESERVE
AND WHAT WE EXPECT.
I URGE YOU TO HONOR AND
SUPPORTER DESERVING SENIOR
HOMEOWNERS BY APPROVING EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIRMAN DAVID JONES A MAP THE
CITY OF SAN MARCOS LIKE TO MAKE
THE AUTHOR. FOR THE HOUSING IS
VERY IMPORTANT SAN MARCUS HAS
SIGNIFICANT MOBILE HOMES SANTA
ROSA ALSO SUFFERED A SIGNIFICANT
A LOSS OF MOBILE HOMES INJURIES
AND. SO THIS BILL BE VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
I JUST WANNA SAY MISS WALDRON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO YOUR COUNTY IN SAN DIEGO AS
WELL AS.
IN OTHER AREAS IMPACTED BY.
FIRE AND OTHER TRAGEDIES AND I
KNOW THIS IS INVOLVES AN ISSUE.
IN THE INTERPRETATION BY YOUR
BUILDING APARTMENTS.
I AM SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT TO
TRY TO PROVIDE MOBILE HOME
EFFORT THAT OWNERS IN RESIDENT
ON PARKS BETTER ACCESS TO THIS
PROCEDURE. NOW WE KNOW THAT IF
WERE ABLE TO CONVERT MOBILE
HOMES FROM PERSONAL TO REAL
PROPERTY THAT COULD PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO THE HOMEOWNER
INCLUDING BETTER ACCESS TO
TRADITIONAL FORMS OF FINANCING.
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH MY
STAFF AND FOR A TAKEN THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AS I KNOW OUR STAFFS HAVE
DISCUSSED I THINK THIS BILL
PROBABLY MIGHT NEED A LITTLE
MORE REFINING AS WE GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS TO GET IT. AT THE
ISSUE YOU'RE TRYING TO TO DEAL
WITH BUT I THINK I GIVEN THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR IT'S
WORTHY OF US MOVING THIS
FORWARD.
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
AND SO WITH THAT AND LESSER ANY
FINAL COMMENTS.
HELLO ASK YOU TO IF YOU'D LIKE
TO HAVE THE FINAL WORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THOSE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES IN THIS
DEVASTATING FIRE AND EVERYTHING
THEY OWN AYE URGENT AYE FULL.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY.
ORSENIGO VICE CHAIR AND WITH
THAT.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS CHU
CHU AYE. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE CHAO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE.
GLORIA. LEE MONTH. THE MONTH I
WOULD.
FOUR ZERO YOUR BILL AS OUT WILL
ADD WILL WAIT FOR OTHER.
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES NOW CALLING AND
SIGN IN ORDER I THINK THAT IS
MISSED FREMONT.
VIOLENT H. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR DEDICATED
WORK ON THIS MEASURE. I'M GLADLY
ACCEPTED THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING PARKING
REDUCTIONS FOR ADAPTIVE REUSE OF
RESIDENTIAL NEAR TRANSIT AND NON
RESIDENTIAL AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
I WORKED WITH THE HISTORIC
PRESERVATION ARE EXPERTS IN MY
COMMUNITY AND STATEWIDE ON THE
ISSUE OF INCENTIVIZING THE RE
USE ADOPTION OF OUR HISTORIC
RESOURCES ACTUALLY COME TO
POLITICS THROUGH. BEING AN
ACTIVIST AND HISTORIC
PRESERVATION AND ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING THINGS FOR ME WHEN I
WAS AN ACTIVIST WAS SEEING
REALLY WONDERFUL HISTORIC
PROPERTIES. SITTING VACANT FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YOU KNOW I
OFTENTIMES EVENTUALLY SORT OF
COLLAPSING JUST BECAUSE THE
BUILDINGS WERE UNABLE TO BE
REUSED A BECAUSE OF A LOT. OF.
MEETING CURRENT PARKING CODES
AND THERE'S A REAL VALUE TO
PRESERVING THESE RESOURCES AND
TO RECYCLING OLD BUILDINGS.
.
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION A PARKING SPACES
KANNADA PURPOSE OF FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND UP TO A
PROJECTS COST ULTIMATELY KILLED
NEW PROJECTS.
INCREASED DEVELOPMENT ALSO OFTEN
PUT TO SORT FABRICS OF THE
COMMUNITIES AT RISK.
ON APPROXIMATELY TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PROPERTIES IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ARE LISTED ON THE
NATIONAL REGISTER OF HISTORIC
PLACES AN ESTIMATED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND REGISTERED ON THE
CALIFORNIA REGISTER OF HISTORIC
PLACES AND OF COURSE MANY MORE
LISTED ON LOCAL REGISTERS. AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE
INCENTIVIZE PRESERVATION OF
REGISTER BY RICK LE OF
REGISTERING HISTORIC STRUCTURES
THAT ARE ADOPTED OR CONVERTED BY
ELIMINATING ADDITIONAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESIDENTIAL USE
LOCATED WITHIN A HALF MILE OF
MAJOR TRANSIT. OR GIVING A
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT REDUCTION IN
PARKING.
REQUIRE PARKING FOR
NONRESIDENTIAL USE
THIS BILL ENSURES A LOCAL IS A
LOCAL HISTORIC CHARACTER IS
MAINTAINED WANT SODOMIZING THE
RE USE OF EXISTING RESOURCES.
FOR HOUSING NEW COMMERCIAL
EXCITER I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION TO CLARIFY AND
ENSURE THAT THE PARKING
REDUCTION INSTEAD OF ONLY
APPLIES.
THE PROJECT MEETS APPROPRIATE
PRESERVATION STANDARDS SANDY
GEORGE REPRESENTING THE EPA IS
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
MR WHICH.
SENATORS REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS AND
STAFF.
SINCE THE BILL WAS INTRODUCED
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT SHE'S AGREED TO
TAKE OUR BIGGEST CONCERN ABOUT
THIS ISSUE IS THAT WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE PRESERVATION
ACTIVISTS IN THE EXPERTS IN HER
JURISDICTION BUT OTHERS AS WELL.
WE DO AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT
THESE PROJECTS WE ESPECIALLY
ADAPTER REVIEWS SHOULD BE.
.
ENCOURAGED IN THAT PARKING
SHOULD NOT BE THE REASON THAT
THEY ARE NOT.
ADOPT AB REDONE THAT THEY CAN
BE USEFUL FOR THE COMMUNITY SO
WE.
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
SUPPORTERS THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MS
FREEMAN.
FIRST LET ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXPERTISE AND HISTORIC
PRESERVATION I THINK.
I THINK YOU'RE THE ONE MEMBER
OF A LEGISLATURE THAT ACTUALLY
HAS A TRULY DEEP KNOWLEDGE IN
THIS AREA AND I ALSO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ADAPTIVE REUSE WE. HAVE A LOT OF
SPECIAL BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA
TO YOUR POINT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY. ARE IF THEY HAVE
OUTGROWN THEIR INITIAL USE GET
PUT TO OTHER USES USES AND A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY STATE.
AND I THINK YOUR BILL WELL AND
BODIES SMART GROWTH IN SMART
DEVELOPMENT PRINCIPLES OF TRYING
TO AND SENT THE RIGHT KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT NEAR TRANSIT.
AND.
AND AND THINKING HARD ABOUT
PARKING WHICH IS VERY EXPENSIVE
FOR THOSE THAT WANT A BILL.
APPRECIATE DOT YOU WORKING WITH
OUR STAFF ON AMENDMENTS AND.
WITHOUT NAM I AM HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD TO PASS AS AMENDED.
MISLIM ON.
OKAY AND HAVE BEEN A SECOND
THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
ATTACK
TO CLARIFY THERE ARE NO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL IT'S BASED ON POLICY
THAT I HAD WORKED ON IN GLENDALE
IT'S WORKED VERY WELL AND I KNOW
THAT IT'S GONNA WORK IN OTHER
PLACES.
RIGHT WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
A CHU BY CHIU MINE MAIENSCHEIN.
CHAU. CHOI.
GLORIA LAMONT. THE MONTH I
WOULD.
ARE YOUR BILL HAS TWO VOTES NEED
TO MORE.
WILL WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS
SUCH A BUSY MORNING THANK YOU.
OVER FILE IN ONE AB SEVENTEEN.
THE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I AM
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK TODAY
ON AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
WE'RE HERE TO ASK YOUR HELP FOR
THE THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS MANY
AND ALL YOUR DISTRICT IN OTHERS
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
UP IN THE MIDST OF TRAGIC FIRES
AND DEVASTATING MUD SLIDES.
THE NEW WEATHER PATTERNS HAVE
CREATED A NEW REALITY FIRES
THAT.
THE SIZE AND INTENSITY OF WHICH
MODERN CALIFORNIA HAS NEVER SEEN
BEFORE TOWARD THROUGH
NEIGHBORHOODS AFTER NEIGHBORHOOD
DESTROYING EVERYTHING IN ITS
PATH.
THE FALL OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FIRES MADE THOUSANDS HOMELESS
FROM SANTA ROSA THROUGH MUCH OF
THE FABLED WINE COUNTRY.
THE NORTH COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
WAS NOT SPARED AS THERE WERE TWO
WERE HUNDREDS OF HOMES THAT FELL
INTO EMBERS AND MORE HEAVILY
DAMAGED
SHELTERS HOMES ONCE AGAIN LOST.
YET IT DID NOT STOP THERE AND
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA OVER A
QUARTER OF MILLION ACRES WERE
REDUCED TO ASHES OVER A THOUSAND
STRUCTURES MOSTLY HOMES WERE
LOST.
THEN.
THEY BORE A SECOND PUNCH
THE MUD SLIDE IN THE COMMUNITY
OF MONT ACETO HIT DESTROYING
OVER A HUNDRED HOMES AND
DAMAGING MANY OTHERS.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY FIVE FIVE
WILL HELP OUR CALIFORNIANS YOUR
NEIGHBORS AND HOURS RECOVER AND
REBUILD THEIR HOMES BY PROVIDING
A TEMPORARY TAX ASSISTANCE TO
THESE DISPLACED HOMEOWNERS.
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS AND WE HAPPILY TAKE
THOSE AMENDMENTS WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOUR STAFF AND TEAM AS
WELL I KNOW THAT THEY WERE
WORKING WITH US UP TO THE FINAL
MOMENTS. UP BUT THE REQUEST
BEFORE US HAS PRESIDENT A
PRECEDENT IN RESPONSE TO THE SAN
DIEGO NORTH FIRE AND THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHO HAVE
WAIVED THE BUILDING PERMIT FEES
TO SPEED UP BOTH THE PROCESS AND
THE REBUILDING OF SHALL. TEARS.
SO ON A IN.
ASKING FOR MANY MANY WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES WE WOULD LIKE
CUT YOUR HELP AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE THOUSANDS OF
CONSTITUENTS WE WHO HAVE LOST SO
MUCH WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THEIR. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE WERE MADE ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
HAVE RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTY WHO
HAVE SUFFERED GREATLY FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS FIRES IN THE
FALL. AND THIS WOULD REALLY HELP
IN THEIR STRUGGLE TO RECOVER
THANK YOU.
FAMILY ITEM YOU HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY LET'S.
.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORNING
HIGGINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND TYRONE BUCKLEY HAD TO LEAVE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WE
WERE OPPOSED AND WE UNDERSTAND.
THAT THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL WHICH WE.
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE BUT.
REVIEW OF WHAT THOSE ARE AND
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE WITH
THAT THE AUTHOR WE WOULD
CONSIDER REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
AFTER REVIEW. THANK YOU.
OTHER OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL A WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION ON A
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED TO THE BILL
CURRENT IS WRITTEN.
GREAT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF ONE. A THIS QUIRK
SILVA APPRECIATE.
YOUR ADVOCACY FOR.
FOR YOUR REGION AS WELL AS FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED
BY NOT RECENT DISASTERS
FIREFIGHTERS ANOTHER FIRE
WILDFIRES AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS. IS UNITE.
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE HAVE A
AND THE FINITE FUNDS THAT WE
HAVE AS A MATTER POLICY ADVOCATE
THIS TIME IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE
A SPECIFIC SB TO CARVE OUT. BUT
AS I ALSO SAID TO THE OTHER
AUTHOR WHO IS HERE I DO THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE IF THERE'S A
CASE TO BE MADE ABOUT.
THAT THE CHALLENGES FACING A
PARTICULAR CLASS OF INDIVIDUALS
FOR US TO THINK ABOUT OTHER
TYPES OF TAX RELIEF AND SO.
I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO AMEND YOUR BILL
AND IF I WILL JUST STATE ON THE
RECORD TO PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT
TO HOMEOWNERS FOR UNREIMBURSED
LOSSES. IN A GOVERNOR DECLARED
DISASTER ZONE BETWEEN JULY FIRST
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS IS NOT A
CARVE OUT S. B. TWO IT'S A
BROADER. AND BROADER TAX RELIEF.
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHICH I
THINK IS A AN ENTIRELY
APPROPRIATE.
POLICY FOR US TO CONSIDER I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE NUMBER
POLICIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERING TO HELP HOMEOWNERS
AND I THINK.
THE SPOT TO BE IN THE MIX ODDS
WITH THAT APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH OUR
OFFICE ON THIS. AND AT THIS
TIME.
WE DON'T HAVE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
IT SO I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THAT WE MOVE THIS FOR AS
AMENDED AT THE PROPER TIME BUT
IF YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
HAPPY TO HEAR THEM. NO I JUST
THINK THIS IS ONE LEGISLATION
WORKS BEST WHEN WE CAN BRING
SOMETHING TO THE TABLE AND WORK
OUT OF THE ISSUES I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO.
BE ON RECORD AS DOING ANYTHING
THAT COULD JEOPARDIZE OR REDUCE
THE SUPPORT FOR S. B. TO KNOWING
HOW OF MUCH OF THAT HAD BEEN
WORKED ON. BLAST MINUTE OR SO
THAT A IN MY AREA AS WELL ON I
KNOW. EVERY CITY IS LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING SOME TYPE OF
SUPPORT AND I THOUGHT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH THE
TAX CREDIT. OF VERSES LA SP TWO
I THINK IS A WIN WIN. GREAT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION AND WILL TAKE UP
THE VOTE AT THE PROPER TIME.
OKAY CALLING ALL AUTHORS CALLING
ON WALTER'S
MISTER BONTA.
THERE WOULD YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR COMIN.
THEN I'LL JUST SAY TO THE
AUDIENCE IS APPARENTLY WE'VE GOT
A LOT OF BILLS MOVING THROUGH A
LOT OF COMMITTEES RIGHT NOW SIR
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
BUT.
LET'S CALL FILE ITEM ELEVEN A.
B. TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE.
MISTER BONTA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS WHO ARE WATCHING ON
VIDEO. AND.
.
AND STAFF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY NINE I WANNA I FIRST
SAY I I WILL ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP.
ON THIS BILL AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY NINE WERE CREATE A TAX
CREDIT TO INCENTIVIZE THE
DONATION OF LAND TO A NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER FOR THE
PURPOSE OF BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AB TWO NINE NINE NINE IS ONE.
MORE TOOL CALIFORNIANS CAN USE
TO HELP IS THE HOUSING CRISIS WE
ALL RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA. HAS
NOT BUILT ENOUGH HOUSING TO
SUPPORT POPULATION THE STATE
HOUSING DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES
THAT WE NEED TO BUILD A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW HOUSING
UNITS EACH YEAR TO MEET DEMAND.
CALIFORNIA HAS AVERAGE LESS THAN
HALF OF THAT OVER THE LAST
DECADE.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A TAX
CREDIT INCENTIVE FOR ANYONE TO
DONATE LAND TO A NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER AND RECEIVE A
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT TAX CREDIT.
BASED ON THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
OF THE LAND. THIS TAX CUT CREDIT
PROGRAM AND HAVE A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR CAP. PER FISCAL YEAR AND
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET. THE LAND
DONATED MUST HAVE A FIFTY FIVE
YEAR DEED RESTRICTION TO ENSURE
THE UNIT'S BUILT ON THE LAND.
REMAIN AFFORDABLE ASPECT WE ASK
YOU AYE VOTE.
I HAVE HERE MICHAEL A NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
MR LINK TORTURED AND MEMBER.
JUST WHAT ONE ENCOURAGE YOUR
YOUR YOUR AYE VOTE IN COMMITTEE
TODAY AS YOU KNOW LANDIS SCARCE
COMMODITY PARTICULAR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
OUT THERE TRYING TO ACQUIRE
LAND.
IN THE MIDST OF A COMPETING
WITH WITH MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS
WE THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
SENATE MISTER BODILY TARGET THIS
BILL. AND AND REDUCED ITS SCOPE
BASED ON PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED A AND
OUR DRIVER.
ANY OTHER WHEN THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THERE'S A MOTION WITH
THE FOR BUYER VICE CHAIRMAN
HAPPY TO SECOND THAT MISTER
BONTA APPRECIATE YOU MOVEMENT
FOR THE SUB VERY INNOVATIVE IDEA
TO. INCENT EMPLOYERS TO DONATE
LAND.
FOR HOUSING.
I THINK THESE OF SORTS OF IDEAS
WE NEED TO MOVE US OUT OF THIS
HOUSING CRISIS AND APPLAUD YOU
FOR IT APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
BUT IF YOU LEADERSHIP MISTER
CHAIR ON ALL THINGS RELATED TO
HOUSING IN PROTECTING OUR
TENANTS I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS BILL
RESPECT WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
AND WITH THAT THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND WILL TAKE AN
INITIAL ROLE. MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE CHAU SHOWING. GLORIA.
LEE MON WOULD. GO AWAY PERHAPS
MEMBERS.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR THINKING
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STEP
RIGHT.
MISTER GIPSON.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
LET ME SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWO
WHICH WILL HELP LOW INCOME
FAMILIES BECOME HOME OWNERS
CALIFORNIA'S FACING. A HOUSING
CRISIS
WITH A LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOMES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO HELP
ADDESS OF THIS CRISIS THIS
PROPOSAL WITH STIMULATE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THROUGH TAX CREDITS.
THIS TAX CREDIT WILL INCENTIVIZE
DONATIONS ON DONORS HIS ME
DONORS TO CONTRIBUTE TO AND.
THE NONPROFIT BUILDING.
HOMES FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THESE PROPERTIES WILL BE LONG
TERM RESALE AND DEED RESTRICTED.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
HOMES REMAIN AFFORDABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY TODAY TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWOS.
BUSINESS MILLER CEO OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY IS A GREATER
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO.
HOLLY.
DAY HAS ZEUS I'M REPRESENTING
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY'S TO ANSWER
ANY TYPE OF QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT
I BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
BILLS MOVE I'M HAPPY TO SECOND
IT OTHER OTHER. SPONSORS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IF IT WORKS MY
NAME'S LIAM MILLER AND THE CO
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING A FORTY
TWO AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WHERE
THE SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE. AS
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA REMAINS IN
THE STATE OF CRISIS WHEN IT
COMES TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE SPECIFICALLY
ARE THE LOWEST SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTIES AND TWELVE OF
THE FIFTEEN MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKETS REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA. HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
OTHER NONPROFIT HOME BUILDERS
HAVE BEEN CREATING AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WORKING LOWER INCOME FAMILY
STRUCTURE FOR ME FOR MANY YEARS.
BUT REMAIN CONSULTATIONS BY THE
RISING COST OF LAND AND
CONSTRUCTION.
IN SACRAMENTO AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THE GREATEST HURDLE TO
BUILDING MORE HOMES IS FINANCING
AND THAT INCLUDES STATE LOCAL
AND FEDERAL FUNDS BUT ALSO
RAISING MONEY TO COVER AT THE
GAP WITH PRIVATE SECTOR FUNDING.
BETWEEN WHAT THE HOME COSTS AND
WATER HABITAT FAMILIES ARE ABLE
TO AFFORD TO PAY. HABITAT
AFFILIATES ACROSS THE STATE
BUILDING A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
WAYS MANY OF THEM HIGH DENSITY.
UNITS I'M HERE IN SACRAMENTO
SPECIFICALLY WE BUILT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO HOMES IN
SACRAMENTO AND YOLO COUNTY. AND
WE HAVE LANDS THAT HAS OVER FIVE
ACRES BUT AM UNABLE TO BUILD ON%
THAT LAND BECAUSE OF THE GAP IN
FUNDING.
TO AFFORD FOR INSTRUCTION THE
COST OF HOUSING SO WELL WE COULD
DEAFENING CREASE.
THEIR HOUSES THAT WE BUILD TO
MAKE A BIGGER IMPACT ON THE KNEE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING HERE IN
OUR COMMUNITY FINANCING REMAINS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST HURDLES. AND
TO SHARE WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A STORY OF A FAMILY WHO IS
THAT THE TYPE OF FAMILIES THAT
WE SERVE.
AT A FILM IT WAS PROFILED ON
NPR AND JUST RECENTLY AND THAT
JIMMY AND PATTY GARRIDO THEY
LIVE IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND
THEY HAVE A FAMILY OF FOUR
DAUGHTERS ALL OF WHOM WERE ON A
ROLL STUDENTS.
PATTY AND JIMMY BOTH WORK FULL
TIME AS ASSISTANT MANAGERS AT A
LOCAL RESTAURANT.
AND SCRAPE BY AFFORDING THEIR.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR.
TWO BEDROOM. APARTMENT THAT
THEY LIVE IN SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS THE ENTIRE APARTMENT
COMPLEXES OVERRUN WITH.
INFESTATION OF
OF.
OF ROACHES AND SAD THE BUT
RECENT STORMS OF BECAUSE HOLES
IN THEIR DRY WHILE THEY PUT
PICTURES UP TO COVER THE HOLES
IN THE DRY WALL. AND THEIR
RECENTLY TOLD THAT THEIR
BUILDING HAD BEEN SOLD IN THE
WOULD BE AFFECTED FROM THEIR
HOUSE NAY BEEN OR THE APARTMENT
LOOKING FOR A PLACE TO LIVE BUT
THEY CAN'T FIND ANYTHING LESS
THAN THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO THEY'RE LOOKING AT
NOW. MOVING SIXTY TO SEVENTY
MILES AWAY FROM WHERE THEY LIVE
WHICH TAKES THEM AWAY FROM THEIR
SCHOOLS THEIR JOB THEIR
DAUGHTERS AWAY FROM THE SCHOOLS
WHETHER ALL HONOR STUDENTS.
AND REALLY DISPLACES THEM AND.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF FAMILY WE
SERVE THEIR ON THE BRINK OF
HOMELESSNESS THEY'RE WORKING
VERY HARD TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE HOME THAT THEY HAVE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. BUT NEED A LEG
UP IN PROVIDING AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR A FAMILY LIKE THIS
SO THEY CAN STAY IN THERE. THEIR
HOMES THEY CAN STAY IN THE
COMMUNITIES TO THEIR CHILDREN
ARE DISPLACED.
THAT'S DOES THE TYPE OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WORKS THAT WERE
WORKING TO SERVE.
I'M AND ONE INCREDIBLE STATISTIC
THAT.
ELECTED SHERIFF USE HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS BEEN MORE THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
ON HOUSING EXPENSES AND ONE
THIRD OF ALL HOUSEHOLDS SPEND
MORE THAN FIFTY. PERCENT.
AT THROUGH AS THE HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROJECTS THAT ARE EXCLUDED FROM
ELIGIBILITY FROM THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM AND
MINISTERED TO AT THROUGH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE IN THIS
PROGRAM. WAS MODELED AFTER
FLORIDA'S COMMUNICATIVE YUSHIN
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WHICH HELPS
PROVIDE FINANCING TO TWENTY
PERCENT OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY'S BUILT IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA. WE HOPE TO REPLICATE
THAT SAME FISCAL IMPACT AND
FACILITATE THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE PASSAGE OF AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWO TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEED HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES IN OUR STATE
WITH AFFORDABLE. HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AND WE HOPE TO
GAIN YOUR SUPPORT NOT.
THANK YOU LIKE SPEAKER. HOLLY
FOR MANY I'M WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN I'M
JUST HERE FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE.
BREAK OTHER SUPPORTERS.
THERE'S NOT A CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
AND ANY OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO VICE CHAIR.
YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANNA I COMMEND THE AUTHOR
OF FOR YOUR WORK NOT JUST ON
THIS BILL BUT IN THIS AREA YOU
BEEN A REAL LEADER AND DIED VERY
INNOVATIVE.
.
YOU NOW REALLY.
WHAT ARE FREE COMMUNITY ON?
OUR YOUR DISTRICT BUT ALSO. THE
WHOLE STATE SO MARK MENU THANK
YOU HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT AND I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
OTHER COMMENTS MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS IS A VERY INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO HELP BUT GENERATE
MORE FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
EVERYONE'S DOWN ON IT.
I DIDN'T WANT OUR COMMITTEE DID
NOT ASK FOR AMENDMENTS BUT I
WANNA POINT OUT ONE ASPECT OF
THE ANALYSIS THAT I HOPE THAT
YOU MAY CONSIDER FOR THE FUTURE.
AND THAT IS POTENTIALLY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN FIVE
YEARS OTHER TYPES OF TAX CREDITS
HAVE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO
THAT WE KNOW. FOR A TAX CREDIT
HOW HOW MANY HOUSING UNITS WERE
BUILT IN THE LOCATION OF THOSE
UNITS IN THE. HOUSEHOLD INCOME
AND REALLY UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT
BOMB SO OUR HOPE IS THAT THAT IS
AN AMENDMENT YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER TAKING AND FUTURE
COMMITTEES I THINK WILL HELP
IMPROVE THE BILL.
NOT SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO
FORTODAY BUT JUST WANT TO
MENTION
THAT. NOW AND WITH THAT THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD WHICH I HAVE SECONDED
ANY FINAL COMMENTS LIKE I WAS I
THINK A VERY MUCH AND.
WEEKS EXCEPT THAT AMENDMENTS
AND ALSO THIS HAS BEEN A
BIPARTISAN.
SUPPORT WITH NO OPPOSITION AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR FOR YOUR OF YOUR GUIDANCE
IN THIS AREA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE
GREAT WELL IF YOUR SUPPLEMENTAL
TO SAY IT'S A DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND.
WE DON'T HAVE THE MOMENT HERE I
GUESS WE CAN'T ACCEPT HERE BUT
WE'LL WORK ON THAT LANGUAGE FOR
THE NEXT COMMITTEE. AND.
WITH THAT DO PASS A MOTION OF
MADAM SECRETARY.
EFFECTIVE THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHIU AYE AYE CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
CHAO.
CHOI. GLORIA LEE MON.
THE MONTH I GOOD.
SO THAT YOUR BILL HE'S ONE MORE
VOTE WILL WAIT FOR THE MEMBERS
TO COME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MISTER STEINORTH FILE ITEM TO
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
SOME.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT. IN SEVENTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT TODAY.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY WILL PROVIDE
THE COUNTY OF SAN MEDINA WITH AN
ADDITIONAL MECHANISM TO DEVELOP
OPERATE IN FINANCE MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING PROJECTS.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION WE WILL
GIVE INCENTIVES TO DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD HOUSING PROJECTS FOR BOTH
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTY OF SANTA DINO.
THESE COMMUNITY SINCERE MEDINA
COUNTY ARE LARGELY UNDERSERVED
DUE TO THE ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
NECESSARY TO BUILD SUCH HOUSING.
OUR SAY POLICIES OFTEN PREVENT
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS FROM
CLIMB THE LADDER OUT OF POVERTY
BECAUSE THEY MAKE TOO MUCH TO
RECEIVE ASSISTANCE.
AND EVEN THEN PURE LOW INCOME
HOUSING PROJECTS CAN PRODUCE
UNINTENDED CYCLICAL AT FACTS OF
FAMILIES LIVING IN HIGH POVERTY
RESOURCE POOR AREAS.
WE MUST TAKE IN ALL OF THE ABOVE
APPROACH AND TACKLE THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA MAKING SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS A GROWING MID IT
MISSING MIDDLE THAT IS OFTEN
FORGOTTEN POLICY DISCUSSIONS.
ALLOWING THE COUNTY TO PRODUCE
ADDITIONAL MIXED INCOME PROJECTS
GIVES THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO
MAKE THE COST PENCIL OUT BY
INCORPORATING MARKET RATE AND
EVEN MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING TO
HELP PAY FOR LOW OF THAT LOW
INCOME. AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL EVERYONE IS GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED THIS
LEGISLATION SPONSORED BY THE
COUNTY OF SAN MEDINA WITH ME
TODAY I UP GUS JOSLIN DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAN MEDINA
COUNTY HOUSING AUTHORITY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
TESTIFY.
THE WITNESS GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN CHIU HONORABLE MEMBER
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT.
AS A QUICK WAY BACK A
BACKGROUND THE HOUSING AUTHORITY
OF THE COUNTY OF SAN BERNARDINO
ADMINISTERS THREE MAIN HOUSING
PROGRAMS.
THE HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
PROGRAM WHICH SERVES OVER TEN
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS. OF THESE
UNITS ARE PRIVATELY OWNED WITH
RENT SUBSIDIES PAID DIRECTLY TO
THE LAND WHERE BY THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY.
THE PUBLIC HOUSING PROGRAM
CURRENTLY SERVES FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO HOUSEHOLDS
THE USER UNITS THAT ARE OWNED
AND MANAGED BY THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY.
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDED DIRECTLY BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT OR HUD. AND ARE
RESTRICTED THE FAMILIES AT OR
BELOW EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME.
GENERALLY THESE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS PAY APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR MONTHLY
GROSS INCOME TOWARDS RENT.
FINALLY THE HOW THE AGENCIES
AUTHORITY OWN PORTFOLIO.
IS A PROGRAM WHICH THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY UNLIKE A LOT OF
HOUSING AUTHORITIES.
WE ARE.
DEVELOPERS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HAVE BEEN SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES
UNDER UNDER THIS PROGRAM WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP OVER THE
YEARS.
OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED UNITS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ALSO
MIXED INCOME HOUSING.
SOME MARKET RATE AT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO OWN AND MANAGE.
THE RENTAL REVENUES FROM THAT
PROGRAM ARE FLEXIBLE.
THEREFORE.
WE WOULD.
BE ABLE TO USE THIS FUNDING.
UNDER.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO
BEGIN TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES.
WE CERTAINLY WILL NOT.
TAKE AWAY FUNDING FROM OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS BUT.
WITH THIS.
PROGRAM UNDER SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WE WILL BE ABLE TO EXPAND
OUR RESOURCES TO.
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FOUR OF HOUSING
FOR MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES.
A A MAJORITY OF OF NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS BEING
BUILT INTO THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF THEIR COMPETITIVE
AND IT AND NATURE OF THAT
PROGRAM THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
HOUSING UNITS ARE BEING.
BUILT.
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES ADDED BELOW
SIXTY PERCENT IN MY. ARE
CONVERSELY THE RECENT STRONG
ECONOMY HAS LED TO A SITUATION
WHERE THE MAJORITY OF NEW MARKET
RATE MULTI FAMILY CONSTRUCTION
IS NOT AFFORDABLE FOR LOW. AND
LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS NO
FUNDING.
PROGRAM NO FUNDING SOURCE
SPECIFICALLY FOR MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING. AND.
THERE FOUR REALLY THERE IS NO.
HOUSING BEING BUILT TODAY
SPECIFICALLY FOR.
THE WORKFORCE OR IN THE MIDDLE
INCOME. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
ADDRESSES THIS DIRECTLY BY.
ALLOWING A HOUSING AUTHORITY TO
CREATE A NEW FUNDING STREAM.
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR THE
MIDDLE INCOME. AND.
WITH THAT I URGE YOU DEVOID
VOTE AYE ON AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
MARY ELLEN SHAKE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES WE WERE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WAS PASSED LAST YEAR. WERE
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
HAVING YOU JOIN US IN THAT
PILOT.
GREAT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
MOTION WITH THE BILL THERE'S A
SECOND.
FOR CENTER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AS YOU'VE NOTED THIS IS AN
EXPANSION OF WHAT WAS MEANT TO
BE A PILOT PROGRAM IN SAN DIEGO
AND SANTA CLARA AND AND
TYPICALLY FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I'D WANT US TO WAIT. TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THAT PILOT PROGRAM
IN THOSE TWO JURISDICTIONS.
BUT.
I AM WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY HAVE FOR A COUPLE
REASONS ONE SAMBAR MEDINA WAS. A
COUNTY THAT IS DIFFERENT FROM
SAN DIEGO AND.
SENT A CLEAR AND I THINK THAT
IS WORTHY OF OUR CONSIDERATION
AND.
ALSO.
I'M SYMPATHETIC TO THE FORMER
VICE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
PARTICULAR YOUR LAST YEAR
FIGHTING FORCE AMBER MEDINA AND
I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT THAT
EXTENSION THE PILOT. THAT BEING
SAID FOR OTHERS WHO MAY BE
THINKING ABOUT THIS FOR THE
FUTURE I DO WANT TO SEE THE DATA
FROM THIS PILOT PROGRAM BEFORE
WE CONTINUE WITH A MUCH LARGER
EXPANSION SO I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT. I DO THINK OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN ADDRESSING
THE MISSING MIDDLE.
IS SOMETHING THAT IS INCREDIBLY
PORT FOR US TO DO SO OUTLOOK FOR
TO THAT DATA.
WITH THAT.
ONE ATTORNEY BACK TO THE AUTHOR
FOR ANY FINAL COMMENTS AYE I
JUST AM GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INTO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIGHT OUT. GREAT THIS
MINIMAL XIN AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS CHIU BY CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
CHAU.
CHOI GLORIA.
LEE MONTH THE MONTH I WOULD. LET
AYE.
YOU BILLS UP TO WAIT FOR ADULTS
THANK YOU.
MISTER MULLIN FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAST YEAR I CARRIED A
BILL. WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
TO ALLOW CITIES AND COUNTIES
STATEWIDE CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES TO FIND
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
PROMOTION. AND DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGH LOCAL
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING WITHOUT
RAISING TAXES.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
LAW VERY STAKEHOLDERS HAVE ASKED
FOR CLEAN UP LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED AB TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES CLARITY TO
THE.
TAXING ENTITIES AND LOCAL
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS COMPLEXITIES IN THE
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT
FRAMEWORK HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES SUGGESTED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX OF YOUR
ANALYSIS. AND I HAVE HERE WITH
ME MICHAEL LANE OF THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MR LAND THE PERENNIAL STAR
WITNESS GOT HOUSING BILLS.
CHURCH SHOULD MEMBERS.
WE'RE GLAD TO REPORT THAT AB
FIFTEEN NINETY WHICH RECITAL
LAST YEAR'S GENERATE SOME
INTEREST OPTICALLY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA FROM CITIES
AND COUNTIES WOULD LIKE TO
IMPLEMENT. AND THIS TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP IS BASED ON THAT INPUT
IN YOUR DRIVER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION.
MISTER MA I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED EFFORTS IN THIS
AREA FOR THE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMMING BEFORE LAST YEAR AND
I KNOW THERE ARE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THIS AND. WE NEED SOME TWEAKS
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS TO. HOPEFULLY MAKE
THIS THE STRONGEST POLICY WE CAN
AND.
THIS
BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDED TO PASS
AS AMENDED RECOMMENDATION TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
THE STATURE AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SIR.
IS OUR MOTION TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD.
MOVED BY DOCTOR WOULD SECOND
I'VE MISSED THURMOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU AYE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAU. CHOI
GLORIA LEMOND.
THE MONEY I WOULD. WOULD GUY.
YOU BILLS OUT WAIT FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU.
TWO MORE BILLS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE DOCTOR WOULD.
SO THE FILE ITEM NINE A. B.
TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN.
TO THE AUTHOR.
MOTION MOVE IT FOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE FIRST LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEES AND
THEIR STAFF AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION IS STILL EMERGING
FROM THE WORST ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
RECORDED IN THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO PRODUCE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
DWELLING UNITS EACH YEAR TO KEEP
PACE WITH CURRENT DEMAND.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE THERE'S
BEEN A BUILDING DEFICIT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ACCUMULATED A
HOUSING DEFINITE DEFICIT OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION UNITS.
WITH THE NUMBERS CONTINUING TO
GROW.
WHILE HOMEBUILDING CONTINUES THE
MARKETABILITY OF HOME
CONSTRUCTION WITHIN A REGION CAN
CHANGE RAPIDLY PROMPTING
PROJECTS TO TEMPORARILY SLOW
DOWN. OR CEASE OPERATION FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME.
THERE ARE NUMBER REASONS FOR
THESE DELAYS LOCAL MARKET
CONDITIONS COMMUNITY REACTIONS
THE AVAILABILITY OF BUILDING
MATERIALS AND EVEN LABOR.
THESE ACTORS ARE EXASPERATED IN
AREAS IMPACTED BY NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS FIRES AS THE
FIRES OF STRUCK ON MY DISTRICT.
HOWEVER THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE STATEWIDE.
CURRENT LAWS ALLOW THESE
BUILDING PERMITS APPLICATIONS TO
BE VALID FOR EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS.
WHILE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO EXTEND THESE
PERMITS IS OFTEN DONE ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS CREATING
UNCERTAINTY TO THE LOCAL.
TO THE LOCAL ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY SOME JURISDICTIONS
HAVE TAKEN SPECIFIC ACTION TO
PROVE PROHIBIT THE EXTENSION OF
BUILDING PERMITS. AND REQUIRE
THEM TO RESTART THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND PAY ADDITIONAL FEES.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN WOULD
PROVIDE THAT A PERMIT. REMAINS
VALID IF THE WORK ON THE SITE IS
AUTHORIZED BY PERMIT IS
COMMENCED WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
A PERMIT BEING ISSUED.
HAVING TO PERMIT REMAIN VALID
FOR THREE YEARS IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED.
PERMITS FOR MANUFACTURED HOUSING
REMAIN VALID FOR THREE YEARS.
THE LONGSTANDING REASON FOR THIS
IS TO PROMOTE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY. RECOGNIZING THE
GOING TO THE END OF THE LOCAL
PERMIT LINE CREATES DELAYS AND
ADDED COSTS.
CALIFORNIA UPDATES AS BUILDING
CODES EVERY EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN
ISSUES NEW ADDITIONS OF OF THE
CODE EVERY SIX MONTHS.
WELL WELL INTENDED THIS CONSTANT
CHANGE CAN INADVERTENTLY CREATED
MINISTRY OF HURDLES FOR PROJECT
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO ONE SET OF
CODES ONLY TO FIND THEY MUST GO
BACK AN INCORPORATE DESIGN
UPGRADES. MANDATED BY THE
CHANGING STATE BUILDING CODES.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS NARROWING THE BILL
RELATED TO.
SPENDER ABANDONED WORK THAT
STRIKES OUTLINES TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ON PAGE
TWO.
AND LINES FIVE TO EIGHT ON PAGE
THREE.
AND.
TO SUNSET THE PROGRAM AFTER
FIVE YEARS.
HERE AT TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS SILVIO FERRARI.
THE SECOND WRAPPED ITS.
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
ESTAMOS THURMOND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SO AGAIN SILVIO PRIME
HALF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF THE CBI
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMMITTEE HAS
THOROUGHLY REVIEWED DISCUSSED
AND THEY HAVE FLAG THIS AS A
HOUSING CREATOR. WE BELIEVE THIS
IS IMPORTANT.
I THINK WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE
NAPRAVI DON'T NEED TO GO INTO
GREAT DETAIL ABOUT JUST HOW.
DIFFICULT IT IS AND IT TO BRING
HOUSING TO THE MARKING
CALIFORNIA ARM IT'S QUITE OFTEN
IT TAKES YEARS YOU CAN TAKE
DECADES TO BE IN A POSITION ON A
PROJECT TO PUT YOUR VERY FIRST
STICK IN THE GROUND.
AND YOU WOULD THINK AFTER ALL
THAT TIME ALL THAT EXPENSE ALL
THAT EFFORTS.
THAT YOUR PERMIT ONCE IT'S IN
HAND WOULD NOT ONLY BE A VALID
FOR SIX MONTHS THAT JUST KIND OF
IS MIND BOGGLING THAT DOWN IT
WOULD ONLY BE AVAILABLE TO YOU
FOR SIX MONTHS BEFORE IT
EXPIRES.
WE HAVE EXISTING LAW ON THE
BOOKS RIGHT NOW FOR MANUFACTURED
HOUSING.
THEIR PERMITS ARE VALID FOR
THREE YEARS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
HAS LONG SAID THAT THE REASON
FOR THAT IS TO TRY TO PROMOTE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY. WE THINK
THAT.
SAME CONCERN SHOULD BE AFFORDED
TO.
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION THAT I
IS BUILT IN THE SITE THAT IS FAR
MORE DIFFICULT FAR MORE COMPLEX
AND. OFTEN A HAS FOR MORE ISSUES
DURING THE ACTUAL TIME.
GETTING TO THAT POINT. ARMS WE
BELIEVE IT MAKES ALL THE SENSE
THE WORLD TO EXTEND THIS TO ADD
TO THAT SITE BILL CONSTRUCTION.
ALSO.
AS. MANY SIM AND JUST SAID YOU
KNOW IT WOULD CREATE A LOT MORE
CERTAINTY FOR US BECAUSE IT
WOULD A LINE THREE YEAR PERMIT
VALIDITY. TO BOB THE BUILDING
CODE PROCESS SO WE WOULD NOT
HAVE UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES
COME UP THAT CAN ULTIMATELY
DRIVE UP THE COST SAID A PROJECT
BACK DOWN THE ROAD. SO AGAIN ARE
WE REALLY BELIEVE THIS IS A
SIMPLE A MODEST BILL HAVING HAVE
TO REALLY POSITIVE IMPACT ON IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WHICH
IS URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS YELLING AVERAGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JADWIGA
SEVERE WITH A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN CABOT
TECH ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHERRY MEMBERS RJ SAMANTHA SOME
BE HALF OF A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION A
SPECIALTY CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT.
THAT'S OUR ASK IF THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES.
WE POLICY OUT FORGET OR LATER
IT WILL BE LATE DIDN'T HANDLE
YESTERDAY.
IT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE MEASURE WAS GONNA BE A
NARROW TO DO MORE THE DISASTER.
AND IT YOU KNOW IT IT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS BUT I THINK THERE ARE
TWO THINGS REALLY.
AT ISSUE HERE ONE IS THE.
YOU DON'T CHANGE YOU KNOW THE
BUILDING CODES DURING A CERTAIN
MY TIME IN THE
PROVIDE SOME UNCERTAIN HELPERS.
WE CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE WITH
THAT ISSUE THE ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE ARE MOST CONCERNED WITH IS
THAT THREE YEAR DELAY ONCE THE
PERMIT IS PULLED. AND IT SEEMS
THAT THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE OF
THE FIFTEEN BILL PACKAGE THAT WE
CALL YOU NOTING DEBATED LAST
YEAR. AND AB SEVENTY THREE THE
THE CHAIRMAN'S BILL THAT
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS SO
BUILDER COULD ACTUALLY USE YOUR
MEASURE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS PULLED BUILDING FROM IT
AND I'M BILL FOR THREE YEARS.
AND IF WE ARE HOUSING CRISIS
WHICH I THINK WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE
WE THINK WE NEED TO BUILD AS
MUCH AS WE CAN AS FAST AS WE CAN
AND WE THINK THAT PROVISION
ALONE. WILL DELAY IT FOR THREE
OR SOME LITTLE UNSURE HOW
DELAYING FOR THREE YEARS IS
GOING TO LEAD TO MORE HOUSING
AND WHAT HAVE YOU THE MEMBERS
ARE EXCEPT IT WOULD CERTAINLY.
TRUMP AUTOPSY.
THANK YOU NEXT.
OPPOSITION.
CITY GEORGE HERBS AND AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
ISSUES SIMILAR TO THE LEAGUE.
AND WE ALSO.
DO WOULD SUPPORT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS WELL BUT
WE ALSO THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE. JUST FOR THAT DISASTER AREAS
WHICH WE WOULD SUPPORT SO WE DO
ALSO APOLOGIZE FOR MIKE IN THEIR
LETTER IN.
GOOD MORNING TRACY RYAN ROW KIND
OF ABSENCE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
POSE LESS AMENDED FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THINKING.
GREAT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE UP LET ME MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE WAS A BIT OF CONFUSION
AROUND THIS BILL.
A LOT OF FOLKS HAD UNDERSTOOD
THIS TO BE FOCUSED ON ON.
DISASTER AREAS AND THAT ACTION
IS NOT WHAT THE BILL WAS DRAFTED
TO DO BUT I DO KNOW THERE WAS
THAT.
THAT WAS THERE WAS A PERCEPTION
AND THAT.
THE AMENDMENT THAT WE HAD
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES THAT WE DO THAT IS ONE
THAT. I STILL. THINK.
WOULD MAKE SENSE THAT BEING SAID
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT.
WITH A ON THE PREMISE THAT
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF AN INTENSE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THAT WHILE WE
HAVE DISASTER AREAS THAT HAVE A
PARTICULAR EXACERBATED
SITUATION.
THAT CRISIS IS ALSO EXACERBATED
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE AND SO
AT THIS TIME THAT AMENDMENT IS
NOT GOING TO BE TAKEN BUT I DO
THINK IT IS A WORTHY
CONVERSATION THAT WE SHOULD.
CONTINUE ON I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S.
ACCEPTANCE OF OTHER AMENDMENTS
ARE TO ALLOW THE PERMIT TO
REMAIN VALID FOR THREE YEARS
FROM THE DATE THAT IT'S ISSUED
BUT NOT TO ALLOW FOR AN
EXTENSION OF AN ADDITIONAL THREE
YEARS. IF WORK IS ABANDONED OR
SUSPENDED.
AS WAS NOTED IN THE ANNOUNCES
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS WHO HAD OPPOSED THE
BILL.
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT WORK STONE'S
AND CONSTRUCTION SITES BEEN
ABANDONED FOR EXTENDED PERIODS
OF TIME.
POTENTIAL MAKESHIFT SHELTERS
FOR.
THAT MIGHT CREATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY HAZARDS THAT IS CONCERNED
I'VE SHARED AS WELL AND THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
AND I'D LOVE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONVERSATION ON THAT I DO THINK
THAT.
THE AMENDMENTS NARROW OF THE
LENGTH OF TIME AS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED BUT.
THERE IS A DISTANCE BETWEEN SIX
MONTHS AND THREE YEARS.
WE'D INITIALLY SUGGESTED A YEAR
AND A HALF WHICH AGAIN I STILL
THINK MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE.
THIS IS AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
BUT I WANTED TO MENTION WHERE
THE MOMENTS OF LANDED.
AND I DO.
ALSO APPRECIATE A A SUNSET DATE
ON THIS UP FOR FIVE YEARS.
WE IT'S WE HAD SUPPORTED THREE.
THE AUTHOR WOULD PREFER FOR
THIS TO BE A DEFINITE.
WE CAME TO FIVE.
THAT DOES NOT GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THIS IS GOING TO GO SO THIS
BILL HAS BEEN A BIT OF A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
WITH A NUMBER STAKEHOLDERS AND
I DO HOPE AND I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION CERTAINLY NOW.
THAT THERE'S MORE CLARITY ON
EXACTLY WHAT THE BILL IS BUT.
WANNA JUST TURN BACK TO THE
AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE COMMENTS
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE BASED ON SOME
OF THE FEEDBACK YOU'VE HEARD.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
IT IS IT WHEN WE LOOK YOU LOOK
AT OUR FACT SHEET ABOUT THIS
BILL WE DO REFERENCE OF FIRES
BUT WE ALSO REFERENCES TO THIS
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A STATEWIDE
ISSUE. SO WAS.
MY DOOR'S BEEN OPEN ON THIS AND.
IF THERE WAS CONFUSION ABOUT
THAT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS
WELCOME TO COME AND TALK TO US
BUT WE NEVER. EVER SAID THAT WE
WERE GONNA LIMIT THIS JUST TO
THE FIRE AREAS SO SO I WAS QUITE
FRANKLY SURPRISED BY THE
OPPOSITION A BASED UPON THAT. UP
IT'S REALLY NOT IN THE INTEREST
OF A BUILDER TO DELAY THERE ARE
THINGS THAT HAPPEN HOWEVER THAT
THAT CAUSED DELAYS. AND A WHAT
BUILDERS REALLY WANT HIS
CERTAINTY
AND WHEN THAT WHEN A PERMIT
EXPIRES AFTER SIX MONTHS AND
THEN BUILDING CODES CHANGE AND
THAT THEY HAVE TO RE APPLY
ADDITIONAL FEES. THAT ISN'T
HELPING OUR HOUSING CRISIS
POINT AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS IS TO CREATE A SYSTEM
WHERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
CERTAINTY FOR BUILDERS. A
UNIFORM STANDARD FOR BUILDERS
AND TO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO WHAT THEY DO BEST NOT TO
BUILD HOUSES.
IS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES AT TIMES IN ACTUALLY
GETTING THAT DONE NOBODY WANTS
THAT NOBODY WANTS TO. IF YOU'RE
A BILL TO EAT THE LAST THING YOU
WANT IS TO LEAVE YOUR PROJECT
ABANDONED. YOU WANT TO GET THAT
DONE AS QUICKLY AND AS YOU CAN
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW. PAPER PAY FOR YOUR OWN
BILLS AND MOVE ON WITH YOUR OWN
FAMILY SO SO I I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH PEOPLE ON THIS BILL
I ALWAYS DO AND.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO IT
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS SOME
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS DO YOU
HAVE ANY. THAT I WAS GOING.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
OKAY WANT ONE FINAL COMMENT ALL
MAKE OUT. I A I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT IS SORT OF UNDERLINE
THIS I DO THINK SIX MONTHS IS A
BIT TOO SHORT.
IS THREE YEARS THE RIGHT TIME
FRAME I THINK THAT'S UP FOR
DISCUSSION ARE I DO ON THE ONE
HAND.
UNDERSTAND THAT BUILDERS DO NOT
HAVE.
A BIG INCENTIVE TO DELAY
PROJECTS YOU WANNA GET PROJECTS
DONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. OF
BUT I ALSO WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS NOT BEING USED AS A WAY
TO AVOID BUILDING STANDARD
UPDATES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
SIGNIFICANT. AND.
AND WHILE IF THERE'S A WILDFIRE
OR ANOTHER DISASTER TO BUILDERS
NOT ABLE TO BILL BECAUSE OF
THAT.
THAT IS I THINK WE WOULD ALL
AGREE VERY LEGITIMATE REASON FOR
ALLOWING A PERMIT TO CONTINUE.
IF ON THE OTHER HAND THERE'S A
DELAY BECAUSE LABOR COSTS HAVE
RISEN OR MATERIAL COSTS HAVE
RISEN AND THAT IS WHY.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
CONSTRUCTION.
FOR A COUPLE YEARS THAT IS A
LITTLE LESS PERSUASIVE TO ME SO
I I DO THINK VERY MUCH THAT THIS
IS A CONVERSATION THAT IS IN
FLUX AND AND NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
THAT WE OTHER COMMITTEES I THINK
IT'S A WORTHY CONVERSATION
BEFORE AND NOW SOMEONE TO. MOVE
THIS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE JUST
DISCUSSED BUT DON'T LOOK FOR THE
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS.
AND WITHOUT HUMAN EMOTION.
OKAY MOTION BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN AND.
WE NEED A SECOND SECOND BY
MISTER GLORIA.
AND.
MADAM SECRETARY LET'S CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED CHIU
AYE TO AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NINE CHAU. CHOI.
CHOI AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
LIMA.
LIMA I. WOULD I WOULD I.
RIGHT BILLS OUT. OF FINAL ITEM
IS MINE AND I'M GONNA TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
.
JEFF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
A PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION FOR
RENTAL HOUSING UNITS.
DESIGNATED FOR MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A
SO CALLED MISSING MIDDLE IN HIGH
COST AREAS OF THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THE PLIGHT OF MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS DURING THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS OUR STATE HAS
EVER EXPERIENCED. ARE IMPACTING
THE SO CALLED MISSING MIDDLE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSEHOLDS
THAT CAN'T AFFORD MARKET RATE
HOUSING. BUT EARNED TOO MUCH TO
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED LOW
INCOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE
MISSING MIDDLE INCLUDES TEACHERS
FIREFIGHTERS EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS HEALTHCARE WORKERS
CHILDCARE RETAIL WORKERS ALL
CRITICAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
OFTEN COMMUNITY EXHAUSTING HOURS
IN GRIDLOCK TRAFFIC EVERY WEEK
FROM LOWER COST PARTS OF OUR
STATE TO HIGHER COST JOBS
CENTERS.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY TO WOULD
PROVIDE A PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
TO DEVELOPERS FOR RENTAL HOUSING
FOR MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
THOSE MAKING BETWEEN EIGHTY AND
HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT AM I IN
HIGH COST AREAS OF OUR STATE.
THE SAVINGS FROM THE PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION WOULD BE USED TO
REDUCE RENTS TO MODERATE INCOME
LEVELS.
DEVELOPERS WOULD ONLY BE ALLOWED
ALLOWED TO CHARGE TENANTS THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME FOR RENT.
AND THE RATE OF RENT WOULD BE
TEN PERCENT BELOW THE FAIR
MARKET RENT AS DETERMINED BY
HUD.
THE BILL WOULD NOT PROVIDE THAT
WOULD NOT TAKE RESOURCES FROM
LOWER INCOME UNITS THAT RECEIVE
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING. ARM
AND AS WE ADDRESS OUR CRISIS I
DO HOPE WOMAN FOR WITH
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS AND WE'RE.
NOT PUTTING FORTH THIS IDEA TO
ADDRESS WHAT HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT.
MISSING COMPONENT OF OUR
HOUSING STRATEGY WITH THAT LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
AM GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS AMY
CHAN FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR'S OFFICE OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
ARE HOW ARE CITY INCLUDING
OTHER HIGH SCHOOL AND AND OTHER
HIGH COST CITIES ARE STRUGGLING
TO MEET THE HOUSING NEEDS OF
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES. WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE OF THE
MISSING METAL.
WE'RE CURRENTLY SEEING THAT THE
MARKET IS REALLY ONLY SERVING
FAMILIES AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME IN ABOVE AND NOT MEETING
THE. HOUSING NEEDS OF THE
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES AT
EIGHTY TO HUNDRED TWENTY PERCENT
OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. AND
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AVERAGE TWO BEDROOM
RENTS CAN BE AS HIGH AS FORTY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
WHERE IS A FAMILY OF THREE IN
THE MODERATE INCOME BRACKET?
I CAN ONLY AFFORD TO PAY
BETWEEN TWO TO THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH SO THAT LEAVES
IT AFFORDABILITY GAP OF A
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER MONTH. AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEING.
MODERATE AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES LEAVE THE CITY.
AND TEACHERS ALSO LEAVING THE
CITY.
SO ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WHERE
I'M STRUGGLING TO MEET THE
HOUSING NEEDS.
OF.
OF MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES IS
ALSO THAT THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION IS INCREDIBLY HIGH
AND BECAUSE THERE ARE VERY FEW
STATE AND FEDERAL SUBSIDIES. UMP
FOR BUILDING.
HIGH HOUSING FOR ADDED THESE
FAMILIES.
ARE SAN FRANCISCO'S ACTUALLY
SUBSIDIZING MODERATE INCOME
UNITS AT ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER BY MORE PER
UNIT FOR MODERATE INCOME UNITS.
COMPARED TO A VERY LOW A LOW
INCOME UNIT. AND THE CITY IS
INVESTING FUNDS INTO BUILDING
MORE.
UNITS FOR MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES AND THREE TWENTY
FIFTEEN HOUSING BONDS SAN
FRANCISCO'S INVESTING EMAIL HAS
BEEN INVESTING EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A MODERATE INCOME
PRODUCTION.
BUT THESE FUNDS GENERATE ABOUT
ONLY TWO HUNDRED UNITS TOTAL
WHERE IS I'M OUR NEED FOR
MODERATE INCOME UNITS IS.
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND UNITS.
SOBRE IN DIRE NEED OF ME I DIRE
NEED OF MORE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AND AN
INNOVATIVE SOLUTION IS TO EXPAND
THE WELFARE TAX EXEMPTION TO
UNITS SERVING UP TO HUNDRED
TWENTY PERCENT OF AND MY. AND
THIS WOULD BE AN EFFECTIVE TOOL
TO INCENTIVIZE.
GREATER PRODUCTION BY REDUCING
THE OPERATING COSTS OF THESE
UNITS I'M WHICH WOULD IN TURN
ALLOW HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO BE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE MORE DEBT TO
PRODUCE THESE UNITS AND THEREBY
ALSO. REDUCING THE SUBSIDY OF.
THE CITY.
FOR.
FOR PRODUCTION AND THAT WOULD
ALLOW OUR RESOURCES TO STRETCH A
STRETCH FURTHER ON TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN OUR
PIPELINE. AND WE JUST SEE A
TREMENDOUS PUBLIC BENEFIT OF
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
OUR.
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES AND WE
AYE AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE FOR THE
BILL THINK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN CHINA MEMBERS
MICHAEL IN WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION TO
CALIFORNIA AND MORE AND MORE IS
OUR IS OUR NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS APPEAR BEFORE
PLANNING COMMISSIONS AND CITY
COUNCILS. THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO
TRY TO INCLUDE SOME THIS MISSING
MIDDLE MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
IN A LARGER LOWER INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND TO DATE WE HAVE
TO SAY I REALLY DON'T HAVE THE
TOOLS THE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT. THIS BILL REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
HELP US MEET THOSE NEEDS AND
RESPOND TO REQUESTS FROM CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS OF YOUR DRIVER.
IF YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT HIS NAME ORGANIZATION
ONLY PLEASE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARIN HIGGINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM WE ARE PLEASED TO
COSPONSOR THIS BILL STRONG
SUPPORT.
HERE ALLEN SHAKE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
pFINANCE AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THAT'LL HELP US GET
THAT PILOT GOING.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S MY NAME'S KEY CEO CARL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR BO WE
VICE CHAIR FIONA MA STRONG
SUPPORT THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
REBEKAH MARCUS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY VAN WE HAVE TO BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NOW HAD ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. ALL MISTER TRUCK.
YEAH BOTH OVER A.
APPRECIATE OF FOR YOUR.
BEARDED OUT TO ENCOURAGE A NEW.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS IS A
CERTAINLY A GOOD INCENTIVE FOR.
ONE OF THE.
THE CONDITIONS USED TO TEN
PERCENT OR MORE.
BELOW MARKET RATE THE HOW.
WOULD YOU DETERMINE THAT
BECAUSE.
THE IN DEPTH TONY SO ANTI OF
TONY AVERAGE JOE YOU TALKING
ABOUT DIE BECAUSE SAYS TO HOUSE
TO HOUSE SO WHAT AREA THE.
AVERAGE PRICE MAYBE.
THERE WAS CRIED DETERMINE THAT
DEALT WITH THAT THAT HAS QUALIFY
TEMPERS. BELOW. SO WE WOULD BE
DETERMINED BY THE FAIR MARKET
RENT.
SET BY THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
FEDERAL EPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT SO FEDERAL
HIDE.
THEIR SAID EVERY FIVE YEARS AND.
THAT IS.
THAT IS THE BEST WAY WE FIGURED
OUT TO IT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT FOR
MARKET RENT IS. SO THE IDEAS
THAT WE PROVIDE A PROPERTY TAX
BREAK TO DEVELOPERS AYE IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO SET RENTS A BIT
LOWER THAN.
THEN THEN THE MARKET RENTS.
SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THIS
PORTION OF THE MARKET AND TO THE
POINT WHERE SPONSORS TO DO THIS
MUCH MORE CHEAPLY. THAN IT WOULD
COST US TO BUILD OTHER KINDS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO HOUSING DEVELOPERS MUST BE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SO.
DOES. IT PROFIT. PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SO THIS IDEA
ACTUALLY CAME TO ME FROM SOME
FOR PROFIT DEVELOPERS WHO REALLY
WANT TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS. OF
THE HOLLOWING OUT OF MIDDLE
CLASS RESIDENTS ARE IN SOME OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA. ARM AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THE HOUSING THAT'S
BEEN DEVELOPED. IS EITHER IS
ONLY AFFORDABLE TO VERY WEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS MARKET RATE HOUSING
OR A.
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS QUALIFY
FOR CURRENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT THE ENTIRE MIDDLE CLASS IS
ESSENTIALLY SHUT OUT OF OF THE
REGIONS SO. WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO AND SCENTED
WITH THIS.
WITH WITH WITH THIS SITE WITH
THIS TAX INCENTIVE.
HOW WOULD IT HURT IF YOU OPEN UP
BUT ANY YOU KNOW?
FOR PROFIT OR NONPROFIT THE IF
THE MARKET RATE THAT THE CHARGES
OF TEMPUS AND BELOW THAT IS SO
GOOD WITH THE ENCOURAGEMENT FOR
ANYONE TO. CONSTRUCT MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES.
I AM SO I'M NOT SURE I FOLLOW
YOUR QUESTION SO WHY WOULD YOU
LIMIT ONLY TO NON PROFITS.
THE CUT FORTUNATELY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
THAT NON PROFITS BE INVOLVED
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION AND SO. UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION IT'S REQUIRED IF
THAT WASN'T THE CASE WE WILL
WELL I I'D ACTUALLY ASSETS IN
QUESTION TO MY STAFF.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS SO
HOT THAT IS THE CASE I'LL JUST
MENTION THIS BILL DID RECEIVE A
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. OF
FROM THE READING TAX COMMITTEE I
THINK THEY'RE MANY FOLKS AND.
ON THE OTHER SIDE THE AISLE
THAT APPRECIATED THE FACT THAT
THIS WAS.
REDUCING PROPERTY TAXES FOR
DEVELOPERS TO AND SENT THEM TO
DO A HOPEFULLY THE RIGHT THING
IN THIS AREA.
AND AGAIN WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE A MOTION.
SAVE A MOTION A SECOND AT JUST
REALLY BRIEFLY I'M.
MISTER CHAIR THANKS AGAIN FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND AS
YOU HAVE ON ALL ISSUES AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT
I THINK THE TEXT.
THE TAX INCENTIVE IS IS GOOD I'M
BY THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT I'M
GLAD TO SEE YOU FOCUSING ON THIS
GET CANNABIS MIDDLE. MADE HIS WE
TALK SO OFTEN. YOU KNOW AND I
KNOW FROM MY SUBJECT LIKE
HOMELESS HOUSING.
LIKE MAGIC BUT THE REP THERE'S
THAT WE NEED HOUSING AT ALL
LEVELS.
HIGHER INCOME HOUSING MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING LARA COMMIT WE
NEED AT ALL AND THAT'S WHY WHEN
THE CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN SOME
REALLY PLEASED THAT YOU'RE.
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON THIS IN IN
THIS AREA AS WELL.
SO THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AS QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAU. CHAU
AYE CHOI AYE CHILI AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE IN THE MONTH.
THE MONTH I WOULD.
WHICH I.
CHIU.
Q. I.
AND THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN TWO
ZERO.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
.
THAT CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH THE AGENDA
TO ADD ON ABSENT MEMBERS ONE WE
JUST START FROM THE TOP THE
ORDER. FILE ITEM ONE. CALLED THE
MISSING MEMBERS.
SEND THIS ONE WE NEED A MOTION
TO MOVE THE BILL FOLLOWERS.
I THINK I WAS THE ONLY PERSON
HERE AT THE TIME IS OUR MOTION
MOTION TO MOVE IT FORWARD AS
AMENDED.
IS OUR SECOND THAT.
CHAIR.
AMENDED TWO TO LIMIT THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL TO JUST
DISASTER.
NO IT'S ACTUALLY FOR.
FROM HIS QUIRK SILVA IS BILL
IT'S AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR.
ATTACKS
AND THE ONE SECOND WE JUST.
GET MY NOTES EXACTLY.
BOB IT WOULD PROVIDE A TAX
CREDIT TO HOMEOWNERS FOR
UNREIMBURSED LOSSES FOR A
GOVERNOR. DECLARED DISASTER ZONE
BETWEEN JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT IS NOT
A CARVE OUT OF SP TWO IT'S A
BROADER. TAX CREDIT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
AND AS I SAID BEFORE WE HAD TWO
BILLS THAT ATTEMPTED CARBON SP
TWO AND IT WITH BOTH BILLS I I
DON'T THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
POLICY BUT. I'D OFFERED TO BOTH
AUTHORS THE POSSIBILITY OF A
BROADER TAX CREDIT AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE CAN FIGHT
OR TOWARD DISCUSS IN THAT IN THE
POLICY CONTEXT OF. EACH OF THOSE
CATEGORIES THAT.
THAT THE AUTHORS ARE INTERESTED
THE BILL IS NOT TAX CREDIT IS
NOT A AMEND S. B. TWO THAT IS
CORRECT. GUESTS HAPPY SECOND
GRADE. ARM. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE GLORIA. GLORIA
AYE LAMONT. FREMONT I WOULD.
WHICH I. FEEL IS OUT SAID BILLS
OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM TO AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT STEINORTH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE. THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN
ZERO FILE ITEM THREE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY TWO FRAZIER.
CHAO.
CHOW AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ONE.
FILE ITEM FOR AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SIX.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHAO.
SHALL I. GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD.
WHAT I?
THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE
ITEM FIVE AB NINETEEN FIFTEEN
MATHIS I HAD AT NO
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS THIS WAS
THE SECOND BILL. THAT ATTEMPTED
TO DO AN SP TO CARVE OUT IN AT
LEAST AT THIS TIME OF MR MATHIS
WOULD LIKE TO VOTE ON THE BILL
UPPER DOWN.
.
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHAO.
GLORIA.
GLORIA NO. LAMONT. LIMON NO.
WOULD.
WAIT NO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN NO.
SO I THAT BILL FAILS.
BY VOTE OF ONE TO FIVE AND THERE
HAS BEEN A MOTION RECONSIDER
THAT'S BEEN GRANTED.
FILE ITEM SIX A. B. NINETEEN
FORTY THREE WALTER.
CHAO.
SHALL I GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD.
WHAT I?
THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO ON
NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE MULLIN.
CHAO.
SHALL I SHOW YOU.
NUMBER SEVEN.
YES FILE ITEM SEVEN MULLIN.
SHOW YOU KNOW.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
THE BILL'S OUT SIX ONE FILE AND
ATE AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE
FRIEDMAN.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHOI NO SHOWING NO.
GLORIA.
JULIA I WOULD.
WOULD I.
FILE ON SIX BUT SIR THAT'S ABOUT
SIX ONE BILLS OUT.
IT'S GO TO FILE ITEM.
FILE ITEM NINE.
MR WEIGHT AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTEEN.
CORRECT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO.
CHAO I.
SO THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY TWO GIPSON.
CHOW. CHOW AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD.
WHAT I?
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY NINE BONTA.
CHAO.
JOE Y. CHOI.
CHOI AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE IMAN.
THE MONEY I WOULD.
WHICH I.
BONTA SPILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO AND
WE'VE ALREADY DONE MY AND FILE
AND TWELVE SO WITH THAT. I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT.
WE HAD A STAFFER WHO.
LEFTIST COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE HAD
SOME HAS BEEN FILLING IN THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS I WANNA THANK
NICOLE RUSS MEYER FOR ALL HER
WORK GETTING US TO. THIS POLICY
DEADLINE AND THE.
YOU VERY MUCH MICHAEL.
AND WITH THAT ARE AT THIS TIME
UNLESS THERE'S ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS AND FROM THE COMMITTEE
WE ARE ADJOURNED